e
I think someone stole my chair so I'll
do the best I can for the for the time
being um um but uh let us start uh if we
pledge repres Paul would you like to
lead us I pled alance to the black of
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stand
Nation
indivisible
andice thank you um we have uh a few
bills to um EXA this
morning and
um there I think several on the actually
on the calendar that um were put on the
calendar um and we have already EXA them
the end of last
week um they are uh House Bill
398 um relative to Holocaust and
genocide studies um we did that on the
5th and that is on will be on the
um was um retained uh also on um last
week uh so 398 and
131 um are off uh the
schedule
um so let's um first uh turn our
which
it is requiring the Department of
Education to maintain student records of
Charter Public School
students um and representative Freeman
did you have a motion yes thank you Mr
second a second thank you very much um
would you like to speak to your motion
yes thank you Mr chair very briefly um I
I moved to um uh in expediate to
legislate this bill because we passed um
another charta school Bill about the
closure of charta schools which
addressed this very issue of maintaining
student record so this this bill
essentially is
duplicative correct any further
discussion yes is there a difference
though between the charter school
closing and the records going over the
Department of Education or a student
finishing the charter school and where
did the records go um the uh if the
charter school is in existence they stay
there but um the uh the bill that we had
um included both more detail on the
closure and things like probation and a
bond if necessary uh but in the last
section addressed um a closing uh
Charter School um and what happens to
bill could you just tell what was that
bill number do you know I'm sorry try I
was afraid you were going to ask that I
yes yeah thank and the uh last section
on page two uh addresses Charter School
records and um I think both these bills
um were discussed with the Department um
and it's just that the uh sponsors um
never got together um on the
topic reverent dry thank you I have um
the sponsor memo on 740 that says the
this bill is makes is requiring the doe
to maintain the permanent records of
represent s thank you just for
clarification and I apologize um for
needing this but for 752 that's already
passed through committee yes and on the
yeah or it will be on the consent
calendar at some point in the near
future as will a number of our other
clerk the motion is itl vice chairman
Noble yes representative Terry yes
representative dry yes representative
Freeman yes representative litfield yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
selig yes representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes chairman
cordelli yes
okay
um I'll just mention um house built
um uh we have um some um late
information um that I got that um I
would like to take a look at more um so
if we could hold that until next
Monday um and I'll just mention that uh
uh I'll give you a list of um our bills
for Monday um but we should be finishing
up everything on Monday so that would be
our only day next week yes I just want
to oh I'm sorry go ahead I just wanted
to ask whether or not that includes the
non-main amendment that is attached to
that or was it no the N was just your um
your changes oh we didn't it's just
intentional KN it wasn't oh yes right
yeah I I don't think it was non gerain
we did have another healing on it we did
oh okay I don't know why it was ruled
n right okay I yeah it yeah I I stand
corrected it was non gerain Amendment
hearing but yes the
whole all thing would be voted on um on
um and uh later on I'll pass out the
[Music]
I think the uh the other bill that is on
schedule
for uh voting today is House Bill 5 side
excuse me
557 relative to the information that
ballots um before we have a motion um
I'd like to have some discussion on this
um if we
might
um
um calls for information to be printed
on the ballot including the average cost
per pupil average daily enrollment for
the prior five years and uh teacher to
discussion R of s thank you um so I I
have some significant concerns about
this bill and whether it could be um
used essentially for electioneering on a
ballot um I also have concerns with as
much detail and information as being
requested in this which would be
available prior to a budget hearing and
prior to a deliberative session to
voters it seems to me this is more
information that's more appropriate to
be on a handout at the deliberative
session than at the ballot um but just
that the extent of copying costs and
everything else that this is a lot of
extra information to be included on a
ballot I know yesterday our my
Cooperative School District was lucky in
only having a two-sided ballot but my
concern is this is going to end up with
multiple pages and and be cumbersome
difficult to
process any other discussion represent
Freeman thank you Mr chair
um we do hear from a lot of our
constituents on the town level that when
they walk into the voting booth that
they don't always have the luxury of
going to deliberative sessions district
school board meetings Etc and I think a
bill like this allow the local
communities to work out the particulars
as as far as what they want to but I
think a a bill like this allows those
districts and the voters to get the full
transparency that they deserve so um I I
of thank you representative maray thank
you Mr chair I also want to be very um
careful here in addition to that um it
is not just the cost per pupil defined
by average daily enrollment but it is
divided out over the total expenditure
over the district so that is
that is a different number than just the
average cost per pupil when just to be
clear um and I I concur with my
colleague representative selig with many
of the statements that she said I'm also
um curious why this information wouldn't
be included in perhaps a town voter
guide instead of it being on a ballot
those get uh distributed often times to
every resident uh to be able to peruse
through there's one for the town and one
for the district usually um that might
be a better place for it to be included
itself Noble thank you Mr chair I I just
want to make a comment about the
election earing um as far as I'm
concerned we already have that on our
ballots we have school board recommends
a yes Vote or School Board recommends a
no
vote rep Woodcock thank you Mr chairman
yeah good morning by the way um if I
um it was brought to our attention
during the hearings that this is a
duplicative duplicative bill law because
the current law which just went in
effect um July
1 this year um mandates mandate certain
reporting in the election so this is
this is
um a waste in terms of value because
it's already in the law and I think it's
was 18976 if I recall right down that
that the attorney from uh Schoolboard
Association brought forward to us so um
that being the case actually I'm not
sure we we want to deal with this in
terms of it's just
you rent Marie yes thank you Mr chair I
think the other thing that we might want
to um just be careful about i f the
record a dis positive vote printed on a
ballot is just stating a public record
um so I don't know while I understand
the memb point um it it's just a
reflection of the outcome of a vote
there was no other statement enumerated
so that's public record that's already
part of a record of a body meeting and
deciding on something um and with that I
you know I also see that there are
definitions uh in the statute that
Define administrator versus full-time
teacher
I am not clear whether or not those
definitions would even be included for
the voter on the ballot when they're
reading those um it it seems clunky and
me res did you have your hand up well I
I did part of it was about the we had I
have a note in my notes that we needed a
further clarification of what
encompassed administrator or what
administrator Encompass because there's
so many things listed I also have a note
that there's nothing about the part-time
staff and then just in response to
representative Noble's point you know if
if the bill simply said a budget
committee um like the school board um
you know approves it or recommends it or
approves or voted you know 8 to six on
this item the budget committee voted six
to eight on this item that would be a
different thing to me and I wouldn't
have an objection to that I just feel
like this is far more information than
belongs on a ballot this is information
brought forward prior to getting to the
ballot prior at the deliberative session
this information would be when it ought
to be
shared thank you R Woodcock just I'm I'm
sure everyone has their red book in
front of them if they if they go to I
have my r book in front of me um if you
go to one
18976 it it tells you if you look at the
four or five six things which the
Republican legislature and the
Republicans on this committee last year
put in um and was passed ass signed by
the governor it cover it has salaries it
has your graph it has administra has
everything you ask for and this bill by
itself that we're look discussing the
duplicate this you already have it it's
starting for the first time
ever so it's like we don't need to kill
camel thank
you um represent B Bon um and I also
want to point out this this very
particular to school district budgets I
mean there's nothing like this on a Town
budget a ballot at the you know it just
it's it's singling out school districts
with information that isn't is skewed
because of the way that it's the
questions are asked I'm looking at
full-time teachers administrators again
a lot of these um information um can
be um it's hard to get an accurate play
I mean what is a full-time teacher what
about therapists uh you know uh par
professionals uh uh so I object to it
because um it seems to be singly not
school districts and it's not something
ballot res
Freeman thank you Mr chair um and and
thank you um representative woodcart for
pointing this out um on 189 um colon 776
however this is just public information
being posted if and now that this has
been codified into law seeing as they
already get this information together
it's going to make it that much easier
for them to print it on a ballot right
there R Paul thank you Mr chair um this
information should be readily available
on the doe
website you know with a new legislation
so I don't it makes no sense to me that
that's printed on a ballot it's there's
enough information on there already
thank you repr
NATO uh I just wanted to say as a a a
resident of New Hampshire for many years
uh it's a
little uh I'm not a techsavvy and
neither of probably the Elder folks in
town so uh so it it does make it a lot
easier for people to say oh it's it's
right here black and white and right in
front of me and they can do their kind
their own comparisons instead of trying
to kind of weave their way through the
web uh thank
you r m again I to the member's point it
is well taken I appreciate that um many
towns across the state print voter
guides and they are
quite all-encompassing there's one for
the town like I mentioned there's one
for the school boards those have Amur
pages that you can then take they're
often sent out uh several weeks uh prior
to voting and you can take a look
through those ask questions attend your
school board meetings I I am unsure what
the cost would then be to the town to
print these ballots with such a
lengthy um description on them and I to
to what end are we going to continue to
put this stuff on the physical ballot I
think we had at least five pages I
believe for our ballot this year without
any of this
r s thank you um just the last thing
I'll say is that in terms of online
sign-ins we have a 10 uh a 10 to1 ratio
right it's um five people wrote in in
support and 52 people wrote in in
opposition to this bill and I think we
need to recognize our constituents are
giving us a clear message they're not in
favor of it ref Noble just on that point
real quick about the numbers online
um for HB 361 and 36
um the the public was in favor of both
those bills one is the mass mandate bill
for schools and the other one was the
centers rent Terry not withstanding uh
the arguments that I heard on both
Sid
uh I know that the information is
available on the doe website I know that
there is information that's made
available at deliberative sessions I
also know the attendance at deliberative
sessions in many of our communities and
I know as well that as I walked past the
poster yesterday on the way into the
polls that most people were just going
right on by it with all of the
information that was provided what I
know is that for many many people the
first time that they are dealing with
any of the questions that we're putting
before them is when they go into the
voting booth and they read what is on
the ballot so where I would prefer a
shorter ballot and I would prefer that
people would do their homework the
reality of the situation is that people
scores of people are not even beginning
to deal with these questions until they
read them on the ballot and they think
about what they're going to do right
then and there thank you I would just
add that um in my town my post office
closed and I now have rural delivery
which hasn't worked out too well I just
got a Valentine's Day card in the mail
yesterday we should have you
going
right um rent maray thank you Mr chair I
have a lot of faith in our voters I
think our voters in New Hampshire are um
well well poised on a lot of things as
Granite Staters we have a lot of
Engagement in our electoral process and
I I would want to make sure that we are
empowering individuals to make the best
choices possible I understand what
you're saying representative but to the
same point we also have to make sure
that we are making fiscally prudent
choices for our towns and our
communities and by double printing this
information in potentially a town voter
guide and on a ballot
I I am concerned that there may be
another vehicle that would be more
appropriate than printing it on a ballot
represent litfield thank you so I just
want to share that the particular
District that I come from it's one of
the larger districts and it's very
interesting because we have a
combination of a school district meeting
we have a town meeting we also have sb2
for the co-op we have zero voter guides
I attend all of it the only thing that's
available to the voters is the annual
Town report which lists the warrant
articles a lot of people just don't
understand it so I do think there's some
validity to putting this on the ballot
also I get what you're saying I think a
voter guide would be great I think there
are concerns about that honestly being
electioneering depending on how or who
puts it out there but I would think that
voter guide would be much more costly
than adding something simple to the
ballot um representative Hall thank you
Mr chair I guess I would ask the
question so what's the next step so if
you go into the voting booth and you see
three people running for Library
trustees and you have no clue who any of
them are you haven't heard about them
now do we have to have descriptions of
who these people are on the ballot
because to make sure that they're
informed I I I'm going to go with
represent Murray and say I think that
our our voters are informed and if
they're not then they should be I mean
putting all this information seems like
way too much thank you Murray um thank
you Mr shair and one other point
regarding this this is a lot of a lot of
conversation around voting and while I I
know that this is germine conversation
to our education department we did not
hear from the Secretary of State on um
any of these potential implications of I
think somebody mentioned electioneering
I I don't know so I I do have
questions um I think that um we would
like to caucus um I I believe that um
representative Cornell that your side is
all set so um the Republicans will go
into the office for a couple of minutes
this
e
I think that um there were some valid
points raised during our
discussion um and I think that um we
would like to uh look at some of those
issues uh more and hold this until
so
um
okay what you reading
going
h
e
some uh clarification um we had talked
about
hb90 and the possible existence of
another
amendment
um we have uh gotten a copy of it um but
we'll just check with the sponsors of
that amendment to see that they intended
to bring It Forward since none of us
have a copy I'm not sure if they
officially um handed that over to the
committee uh or not so we'll check with
them um and then bring up hb90 uh this
everyone yes how thank you how many
amendments are do we have for
hb90 for hp90 um my I think just two two
yep I'll open the executive session on
House Bill 699 relative to special
education definitions and I recognize
representative cordelli for a motion uh
thank you uh I would like to move a to
pass with Amendment exuse me um yeah
ought to pass and I will second
represent cordelli uh thank you uh I
would like to um offer Amendment
H and ought to pass on that
gave it out last yeah she wasn't here
want me
to
copy
okay represent dry is going to make a
somewhere did you need a copy
oh yeah
if if if while we're checking amendments
um the the other uh Bill we were going
to bring up is uh
754 HB
754 um and there was an amendment to
that which is
H that was uh automatic Discovery and
it's coming here shortly
okay
okay oh okay yes right
yeah so should
we what are we doing
Glen
right
[Music]
699 who did you work with yeah wait who
did you work
with you work with somebody this um just
do
699 does everyone have um the amendment
for
754 if if if so maybe we can do six
excuse me 754 or we waiting for the
copies can you do that if you got it
open we have hear on the floor yeah oh
I'm sorry yes you're right we do have
um maybe we're waiting for the ACT
actual copies um maybe I could do some
uh explanation of the of the amendment
yeah
[Music]
got all
[Applause]
representative cordelli would you like
to discuss the amendment uh thank you
very much
um there were a number of
um uh points raised during the
hearing um we uh subsequently worked
with
uh m de from the Department of Education
special direct director who talked to a
number of people um at the hearing um
and this is the result of our
conversations with her and uh her
suggestions in terms of um what would um
be appropriate to be added to these uh
definitions and I'll just mention that
these um are
definitions uh related to special
education um and they are an outgrowth
of the uh audit that was done um last
year uh which um had comments in it um
that uh uh called for some additional
definitions being being added to statute
they in some cases they were in rules
but not in statute uh so it was um
recommended they be put into statute
also um so um these were those uh
instructions um plus one other thing
that um we did on the bottom of page two
um also as a response to the discussions
um we
changed um starting on line
28 um functionally blind pupils to
students with visual
impairments um and made uh that change
in um RSA 186
c7b now was the one other change in
addition to the uh definitions that were
hearing since I'm the second I have no
other comments any other
discussion okay representative bbon
um I find that there's still a number of
questions that I have about this bill um
because of um and and I don't think your
second amendment really addresses all
the concerns as well I I wonder I don't
I I know you it has been said that
stakeholders were um involved in
discussions but I I I have heard
otherwise and that I also have some
concerns about going out and changing
this this is a lot of language that it's
very important to a lot of people and
you heard from them when they came and
objected to it I don't think these
changes are solve the problem I think
the bill the some of is still clunky um
I question I see on the this amendment
the Charter Public Schools were added
and I if I look in particular at line 16
and 17 where it says this environment is
managed by the uh School District
Charter Public School Etc well um um
when special ed students attend Charter
Schools it's the responsibility of the
school district Lea to take care of um
to manage that child's special education
and so it's a little confusing if you
put it in here and say that um put that
responsibility on the charter schools
whereas again I think you heard um
before with that bill 222 that came in
there's awful lot of confusion between
the charter schools and the School
departments in terms of uh delivery to
special education um services to those
children in special in in charter
schools so um and also I if you're
talking about the audit of the special
uh uh dispute resolution processes I
don't specifically remember having this
language being brought up as necessary
changes there were definitely some
comments about saying that uh the state
needs to better align their definitions
with um the federal definitions and I I
agree with that but I do know that
there's another a more comprehensive
audit that is going is happening right
now within the whole special education
department and it seems to me that it
would be most um diligent of us to wait
for that whole audit to come out and not
and why and instead of trying to do this
Pac mail before we figure out what other
definitions need to be changed um so I
would recommend retaining this until we
get the results of that full uh special
education audit which I believe is going
to coming out um this year maybe
chairman cordelli knows when when that
still out but it seems to be um
irresponsible us to rush forward with
something so important to so many people
thank you representative cordelli uh
thank you um the section related to the
education environment
um I think was specifically addressed um
because the department wanted to make
sure that uh suitable facilities were
being used um there had been in the past
some uh reports of uh uh students being
placed in rooms that might not be
suitable and that uh they wanted to make
sure that those students were in
um representative dve thank you and I
just wanted to point out that one of the
um comments in the hearing was that we
did not refer to federal law in some of
the definitions that we said we were
trying to emulate or or um at least um
get on record in our statute and I want
to say that this does that in all of
those places where exactly as it was
do represent muray thank you um Madam
chair um
I I am concerned if uh there were not
stakeholders consulted with this
amendment to representative Bon's points
um this is a deeply impactful piece of
legislation to a group that
struggles almost routinely to be heard
and seen in places that um creating if
that is the case I I I would encourage
us to just take a moment and maybe have
a different conversation if that has not
discussion representative Hall thank you
madam chair um to Echo what uh
representative Murray said when we sat
at that hearing there were many many
angry people out there many um and when
that hearing ended I really thought that
the key stakeholders were going to sit
down I don't care if it was on Zoom or
sit down in a meeting and really come up
with something that they could all agree
to that to me has you know when I hear
you know the doe I heard uh Rebecca
Fett's name mentioned but we're talking
about all those other other stakeholders
why why is this here without their input
or did did we get their input and we
didn't like it um I guess I would that's
my question to whomever would know the
answer what happened to those
folks and their
input representative cordelli thank you
I just comment that there were a lot of
angry people at that hearing because
there had been a lot of misinformation
about this bill uh being put out by or
two groups um so that's why there were
angry people here who uh did not
understand and were misled about uh the
say thank you um I would say that if if
those people were confused or misled I
don't think we've done anything then um
to reach out to them and really it tell
them what what this is especially if
this bill if this amender is being
crafted with only a few people involved
so if we truly want to put something
forward
that with the intent that I think
everyone wants is that they understand
what is being done in here then I would
I urge us to hold back and and do it the
right way and I I guess I still don't
understand why we need to rush this
through right now when we know that the
you represent muray thank you uh Madam
chair
um I do recall there being questions and
clarifications during the hearing there
were also additional statements uh and
and desires to be involved in the
process of the Drafting and if that
didn't
happen uh when this was crafted I think
that we do owe it to the group whether
whether the the feelings from the
membership you know interpreting certain
statements around misleading or not I we
owe it to that group of people to make
sure that this has
been um at least worked with alongside
of
them representative
Freeman thank you madam
chair representative
cordelli you've written many amendments
over the years
and I don't remember this amendment
correct that is correct this was not a
study committee this was an amendment
and um I think with all the testimony
that we did hear that particular day and
the misinformation that was floated
around in the atmosphere um we heard
everyone that spoke that day um and I do
believe that representative cordelli
heard every one of those person's
concerned so I find it a little
disingenuous when I hear that nobody had
any input into this when we had a full
hearing we heard many different people
on this subject and um you know I we can
beat this to death and we can we can go
back and forth on how many people should
be involved in an amendment but I I
remember a lot of amendments having a
lot of people sitting at the table doing
the Amendments if that's a study
committee then we'll put in a bill for a
study committee but that's not what this
was I just want to make a comment about
the audit because the way that I took it
this did not come out of the dispute
resolution audit that we had last year
this was part of the ongoing audit and
because they felt it was important
enough to make the change now and not
next year when um when that audit is
complete and um for for a couple of
reasons I think that had to do with the
approved educational
environment um to make sure that they
weren't in closets or boiler rooms like
we
heard um as well as the
the section that had to do with related
Services where we only had a portion of
that in state law so someone could
interpret that as this is all the state
is doing so that was why this came
forward now versus when the audit is
representative dve thank you I think
this is a reflection of all the input
that we got at that hearing especially
the part about approved educational
environment not only does it incorporate
putting in in a decent environment but
also incorporates the least restrictive
environment uh Clause that everybody was
concerned about the special definitions
that are in Roman numeral five
and uh seven and down below below are
taken from the federal law there's
nothing new here it's and it's reference
to the state law it's the law that we've
been operate or this federal law it's
the law that we've been operating under
it just now enumerates it and refers it
to the federal law in our
statutes representative Hall thank you
madam chair I would just like to say
that I think drafting an amendment with
stakeholders is not a study committee
you you you're getting input to draft an
amendment that's it it's not a study
opinion any other discussion
representative Bon um I just following
up on representative Noble's comment if
it if it does come from the audit that's
currently being um happening now I think
it would certainly clear up a lot of
information if that audit was public and
you could see where those um and it
would make more sense and it certainly
would give this amendment more uh
validity to and perhaps be more
supported by those folks that that had
some questions about it but as far as I
know there there hasn't been any uh
sections of that audit made public yet
otherwise represent Cornell Thank you
madam chair I I just think there are
still so many questions so much
disagreement um you know whether it was
through misinformation or not
3,268 people were opposed to this bill
that's that's a lot of constituents
whether they're whether they're confused
about what was intended whether they
heard misinformation that's still a lot
um and I would be more comfortable
retaining this to work on it more it is
so important um and there are so many
people that are still going to be not
understanding what's happening because
of the misin maybe misinformation maybe
misunderstanding um fear of what's going
to happen I think retaining it and
working on it more working on it with
more stakeholders um getting more input
from the um audit would just make more
sense to
me represent maray um thank you madam
chair and I I I also even in the first
paragraph of the proposed um Amendment
uh for 0606 we are I have not seen
legislation in a long time that has the
and
slor and I I think that this is opening
the door for people to make choices
about how they're applying the um
there's twice in that first paragraph
where there is exceptional language for
Andor um and and so it it seems a little
bit subjective to me as far
as an opportunity for interpretation one
way or another that could also um have
unintended consequences and I I just
wish that we would
pause that um that first section was um
language that we got from the Brain
Injury
Association on the um they acquired
brain injury
is that that's that what you're talking
you're representative cig thank you I I
was just hoping I maybe could get
clarification and I apologize that it's
taking me a minute to process all of
this but um looking at paragraph um
Roman numeral two where it says approved
program means a program and it gives
this list um but it specifies within the
school district and I just think about
the does this therefore exclude people
who might be sent to an outof District
placement I'm I'm just trying to make
sure that I understand fully and and so
moment oh this is on the amendment I'm
sorry um approved program means a
program of special education within the
school districts
representative Celli yes I you're you're
looking at the original Bill no on the
amend
Amendment
page it's it's like lines um on right
the first page of the amendment
yeah that's 11 is yeah that's uh I
Bill I'm still curious what happens if
they're being placed outside of their
District right I I I think that this is
um they facilities other private
providers um I I think it's intended to
cover right bu you know any any
discussion seeing none Madam clerk
chairman Noble yes Vice chair yeah sorry
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative litfield yes
representative tenar yes representative
moris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell no representative
Murray no representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no representative
bon no Representative selig no
representative kuger no representative
Snodgrass no chairman cordelli yes nine
Ys eight
[Music]
Nays recognize representative cordelli
for a
motion yes I would like to move on to
pass as amended with Amendment
no no more
clerk chairman Noble yes representative
Terry yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell no representative
Murray no representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no representative
Balon no Representative selig no
Representative kuger no representative
Snodgrass no chairman cordelli yes nine
Nays that closes the executive session
on
699 we'll open the executive session on
House Bill 754 FN establishing automatic
discuss Y and due process hearings for
actions seeking to enforce special
education rights and I Look to
representative cordelli for a motion uh
thank you I'd like to move on to
second second representative litfield
seconds representative cordelli thank
you uh yes uh I put forward a motion of
a to pass and I would like to now offer
Amendment
H has ought to pass on that is there a
second on the
amendment I'll second representative
Freeman
seconds discussion on the amendment
representative
cordelli uh yes
um this uh
Amendment um was uh drafted to um
respond to some of the uh comments um in
the original um uh Bill and this was
worked on um in conjunction with uh the
special education Advocate who um worked
with a number of um uh Advocates that
she knows of and that were some that
were in attention excuse me in um in the
and this is all related to if I might
add um automatic Discovery so
information that uh are core documents
that should be available um to uh
parents um in a due process
hearing representative Freeman did you
have any comments I don't at this time
thank you m chair any other discussion
representative selling is there an extra
copy or two of the amendment handy just
I don't seem to be able to find M eny
because I was not here have an
[Music]
extra representative
Bon um yeah so I thank you I just want
people to understand what this actually
does because it's it's confusing and it
took me a while to kind of figure it out
so I what currently um
um this information is not typically
disclosed at a um in advance of the
prehearing conference the purpose of a
prehearing conference is to narrow the
issues um so so what we're actually
doing in this Bill is saying that all
this information has to be released
prior to that um now a prehearing
conference uh sometimes leads to a
ruling that certain claims will not be
heard um because bared by the statute of
limitations or because the hearing
officer lacks uh jurisdiction over them
so requiring a school district to to
close Court exhibits before the
prehearing conference could um lead to a
lot of information being released to
hearing officers um and it could be you
know more work instead of instead of the
if the purpose was to simplify it I
don't think that is what it's doing um
so it it puts the onus on the school
district to provide all that information
in advance and it could be duplicative I
mean it it's a lot of extra work it's a
lot of um extra money for documents that
will and are available to the parent
already if they ask um so I I will not
be voting for it for that reason thank
discussion seeing none Madam clerk
amendment chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman
absolutely representative litfield yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative
Murray is I'm sorry is the mo motion on
the amendment okay yes
representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no representative
bon no representative selig yes
representative kuger yes representative
Snodgrass
no and chairman cordelli yes 13 Ys and
four
Nays representative cordelli do you have
another motion yes thank you very much
I'd like to move out to pass
as amended with uh Amendment
second representative moris is
second any other
discussion seeing none Madame clerk the
otpa Chairman Noble yes representative
Terry yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative
Murray yes representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no representative
bon no representative selig yes
representative kuger yes representative
Snodgrass yes
representative cordelli yes 14 Ys and
three
Nays cons
consent yes consent no Minority Report
no
much um I thought they handed I handed
yeah I believe that
um that finishes our bills for this
morning as there are uh a couple that we
were going to hold off uh over until
Monday um so we will resume at 1:00 with
uh several excuse me um
actually at 1:00 we're scheduled for
695 um and that was an error in
scheduling in that we already EXA House
Bill
um oh no that's right no we we had the
hearing on it yes um
right um so I think procedure wise um
since it's listed in the calendar I'll
just open the hearing
close it um and then we'll um actually
get started at45 with
768 so if um if you would like to uh
skip hearing me open and closing uh 695
um perfectly uh entitled to do
that um so otherwise we'll we'll start
actually with uh 768 at 145
446 and 431
represent you also going to be back 90
right this afternoon we'll do that on
Monday Monday my era thank you right
yeah 90
695 and uh
431 did you make copies of this on
Monday
oh
no yeah I'm
sorry yeah I'll make another
much
e
okay we will open the hearing on House
Bill 695 FN relative to school districts
and medically related grants this is a
continuation
hearing and I call Aubrey fredman to
testify
uh Madame chair committee members uh
Aubrey fried I live in Bridgewater so I
missed the hearing last week and I did
already email uh all the committee
members so I'll just make one point
today which is on the the way the set up
now with accept you know applying for
and accepting a grant so school
districts they practically apply for
every possible Grant but they do have to
have a public hearing before accepting
it and I've gone to Schoolboard meetings
and these hearings for years nobody
knows about them nobody attends them
they're
hardly you know they just kind of slip
through and there's very little
testimony at all on them one way or the
other it's usually just the school
district um saying why they think it's a
good idea it should be accepted and
that's the end I can only remember one
Grant Hearing in like four years I've
been going to meetings and hearings
where there was actually discussion and
opposition they still accepted it anyway
but at least there was discussion I
think it makes more sense to have uh the
uh discussion go before somebody's
already done the work to apply for it
cuz once they've already applied it's
like well we may as well accept it
anyway somebody spent the work and at
Town meetings they actually have decent
attendance where people show up people
don't come to these hearings they barely
know about them so it makes sense to me
to have the um discussion beforehand
before somebody puts in the work to do
it and uh at the town meeting where
people can actually discuss it if they
vote forward well at least there's been
a a fair hearing and discussion on it
rather than just rush the whole uh
project through without really any
discussion so that's why I support the
Bill thank you thank you any
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you and that will close the
not
e
goodby here we go good
afternoon we will open open the hearing
on House Bill
768 we have uh three hearings this
afternoon 768 is allowing public schools
to contract with any approved uh private
school and the prime sponsor is here
represent Vice chairman Noble thank you
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee for the record I'm Kristen
Noble and I represent Hillsboro District
2 the town of
Bedford um this is actually a very
simple bill it's just um language
cleanup um from a bill that was passed
and signed in
20121 um the the reason I I found this
was because I was doing a little bit of
research on Supreme Court decisions that
had to do with school choice and so I
came to
um uh one uh decision that was uh Carson
versus Mon and that had to do that was
in from Maine and it had to do with Town
tuition and
um being able to um use that the town
tuition to go to a religious school and
as part of that I found an article that
said that Governor sonunu had signed a
bill um that allowed this and I think um
that is what
allowed um uh there was a case Cen I I
think where they wanted to use um the
town tuition money to go to a religious
school
um so the first section I I was trying
to find what the bill was and um but I
ended up searching the rsas and the
first one I had come to was this 191
1-A um and that you can that's page 478
and so
um that says pursuant to RSA 193 col 3
Roman numeral 6 a school board May
execute a contract with any approved
nonsectarian
private private school approved by the
school board so 193 colon
three Roman
numeral
six um that word non sectarian had been
um removed from there and that was the
the bill that the governor had signed
back in 20121 so this is just cleaning
up that that one word and that's
it thank
you um questions for the representative
represent Woodcock thank you good
afternoon by chairman good afternoon so
just to be
clear um and
1933 and your bill here the only thing
you're doing is removing a word that's
already been removed
mhm so in I see the bill in in
parentheses not secan through
it but it's already is it my associate
here looking up trying to in
um in 193 col 3 yeah Roman numeral 6
here a page on that difficult that 539
539 sorry I thought I I have it okay
okay that's right so the word was
removed from there and so this this um
189 colon 1- a is Roman numeral 4 which
is Page 478 is saying pursuant to RSA
193 col 3 Roman numeral 6 and then it
has
the language of of um cross yeah just
Crossroad yeah yes thank you we just
cross ring yes yes thank
you right um I I think actually this
might be the
third um incident uh instance we've seen
that we missed in the original uh Bill
to cross out that
discussion seeing none thank you very
Freeman uh Mr chairman committee members
uh Aubrey Friedman brid S I speak in
support of this bill well I didn't
realize that this just sounds like this
was an oversight I definitely think uh
but I'll just make a quick point I think
religious schools are fine it's good to
have more options and religious schools
they actually have higher standards than
uh reg traditional government schools
when my son went to Catholic school and
I went to a tour of the school um I was
amazed they actually said what the
grading scale was you know like 9080
7060 and their A's ended at 93 and B's
ended at like 85 and then 77 and then 70
that was it so they have very high
standards so I think religious schools
are good and it's good to have more
options and I'm glad this is just fixing
a little clerical problem with the law
thank you thank you uh
questions see none thank you very much
thank you um was there anyone in the
audience who wished to uh furiously
filling out my pink C
okay thank you good afternoon for the
record my name is Diana Fenton I'm an
attorney with the Department of
Education I would like
to address the issue that was
raised um if we look at 193 colon
because that's the cross reference in
the bill that you're considering is a
cross reference to
1933 I want to bring your attention to
page
540 and I'll give everyone a moment to
may if you look on page 540 in the right
hand column Under The Heading amendments
where the print gets really small and I
think to myself I should really call my
eye doctor again right because this is
where they talk about the changes that
have occurred in the
past it's great to rely on historical
memory I rely on mine all the time and
then I realize it's not as good as it
used to be I would encourage this
committee to look in this section here
under amendments notably
where the Bold says 2021 talks about the
Amendments that were
created not too long
down this is paragraph six chapter 106
colum 2 now that's very deep in the
woods on statutory instruction where
they talk about the chapter number but
it it says it rewrote the paragraph
which now we'll read as follows
and it recites the law and it has the
non- secretari in there so then it was
removed and that's what this bill is
trying to do this bill is really a
cleanup a technical bill that's trying
to match the language but now that this
bill is in front of this committee for
its consideration I would encourage this
committee to look at that Amendment
section and it will talk to you about
the history of of 1933 because 933 is
one of those bills that we talked about
during the um opportunity that I had to
come in front of you to provide some
training 19 through3 has been amended
quite a bit and I will share with you
that um when I have to dig into the
really get into the Weeds on legislative
interpretation and legislative
history the person that I turn to really
is Jen right in the corner there she's
an excellent researcher sorry Jen I just
outed you I'm sorry sorry she'll never
forgive me um this is a great place to
start this amendment section look at the
language and I think in looking at it it
will be clear that this really is just a
technical cleanup bill so that the
language is matching I'm happy to take
any questions but I wanted to take this
opportunity to highlight that for this
committee's consideration I appreciate
your
time any questions represent woodcot
thank you CH good afternoon ter Fenton
um just just a question so what happens
if the bill doesn't pass
is this build as
the and then you have an inconsistency
in the
law
happens you make the position s go
ahead so when you have an inconsistency
in the law then you have to get into
statutory interpretation and part of
that is looking at the history of the
bill which one was changed last and so
you would defer to 1833 and you look at
that history and you'd see that it was a
technical oversight um and my
understanding although I can't recall at
the top of my head is that other bills
have come before this committee to
identify areas where that language is
used and and strike it so I think the
legislative history would support that
interpretation that the inconsistency is
really an oversight um but that's what
would happen is you would have a
thank you any further
questions resident
Bon thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so I'm just wondering
so it applies to two different things
though right I mean at the beginning um
this section is about oh manifest
hardship and if I I'm going to the
beginning of the section um which I just
lost uh because I was on the amendment
um oh uh 1933 all addresses the change
of school or assignment in the best
interest of the student whereas an um
where it the other change was made is
just in the general uh School boards
transportation and instructions of
pupils
so was it applied to different things I
mean I mean if if if it's hardship or
you know and do do you understand what
I'm saying it seems to me why
why why does it need to be in two places
I
guess I think it was brought forward as
that technical correction to make sure
that the laws were consistent in the way
I view 189 col 1A the duty to provide
education is more kind of a a basic
overview
it is a general statute um and when I
look at
1933 that is more detailed the
application of it but I don't
think I don't think it changes the
meaning of it I think it's consistent in
terms of striking the non- secretari so
that the two sections
match followup sure um so so if I read
it one is talking about the contract as
opposed to the ability to do it perhaps
I mean um the first part talks about the
allowing the school boards to
um uh have a contract within with a non-
secretary school and this one talks
about um again it seems to be just
talking about allowing them to enter
into a um tuition agreement so it's same
thing one is general and one is
more detailed as to how it happens
is
that I don't necessarily like that
characterization represent
Murray thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking my question I'm curious to know
whether it's the the actual word non
sectarian that is uh being cleaned up or
is there is there um disconnect between
what exists in con State constitutional
law and then the changes in the in the
RSA uh regarding payment for religious
entities I I do know
that um the state constitution still
talks about things uh with regard to
religious sex or denominations paying
for certain services so I'm curious how
the removal of that word stands
maybe in conflict with what the state
constitution says
an interesting question without the
state constitution in front of me I I'm
not in a great position to kind of take
that deep dive answer and surprisingly I
don't have it memorized in my head um as
some people think I I probably should um
to the best of my understanding the bill
that's brought before you in HB
678 is is really just a a technical
correction Bill there was no discussion
about the implications of the state
in what's the word I'm looking for it
completely escaped my head but um there
was no discussion nor was there any
thought as to whether there was any
violation there it was just viewed as a
technical
correction represent
Freeman thank you Mr chair thank you for
coming in front of us so is it your
understanding that this bill does
nothing to change current statute but
instead codifies the language that
should have been matched from the first
yes representative
litfield thank you Mr chairman and thank
you attorney Fenton for taking my
question
um so in reading this and I don't and I
don't know if this if I'm even allowed
to ask this question so you can stop me
but um is it if we don't correct this
will it hold up in a court of law
I feel like that's what I feel like
that's kind of why I can't say it
but
um I think that is kind of the natural
piggyback to representative woodcock's
question um and and again it would just
go into statutary interpretation and
statutory history as to what the
legislature intended exactly with that
change right thank
um I'm going back to uh on the amended
section the six on six so is this is it
just the first uh line for my clarity um
on page 540 that you referenced it to in
the small print okay so is this bill
only specific if there is
no if there's no public school with
that's what RSA 1933 is talking about
on yes I just want to be really clear so
the only this the application
disregarding the the dialogue today
about nonsectarian the application
specifically is only for a school system
if they don't have that grade in the
public school system is that
correct that's what 1933 talks about but
I think that if you if you put the
statutes together again my understanding
in working with the sponsor of this bill
this is a technical correction
bill and I think the sponsor me um the
sponsor put it best is that this really
is a straightforward bill this was
always intended to be a technical
correction Bill and 1891 a is that
General provision right which then
allows
1933 to go into detail about what that
detailed examples I hope that helps
clarify it a little
bit all right but again I would just uh
encourage this committee to look at that
history in the amendment section because
legislatively see no further questions
thank you very much was there anyone
else who wish to
testify uh see none
we'll close the hearing on
hearing
e
we have a number of people who would
like to speak so um since this is a
continuation of the hearing um we'll
limit testimony to three minutes uh per
person and we will start with
representative
B yes question pleas sure thank you so
is the dialogue this afternoon going to
be dealing with the uh amended Amendment
that's been placed placed
in are we talking about
um talking about the amendment of the
bill well the Amendments already been
put in right I has the amendment
yeah must be in yeah I I I don't have
mine so oh um mine has the right
answer can I get yeah I I I just want to
clear honestly on which what we're
addressing this afternoon representative
right I I believe that the uh amendment
was introduced so we can speak to the
thank you representative B welcome thank
you uh this is I'm Ralph B Hillsboro
District 38 the towns of litfield and
Hudson and Deja Vu again and again and
again I've been for those that don't
know I used to be on education committee
for 12 years and I decided I needed a
rest anyway some years ago I introduced
the bill to put a rain in on
non-academic surveys parents had to be
notified in questions provided first
bill was flopped out then it was later
change oped in Bill finally passed and
it's now law and then as multiple tries
to change it arguments in that sub that
schools in some cases get money for
doing the survey selling student
information for money I guess is okay
for some the youth risk behavior survey
was left
in to be opt in this survey is taken as
a joke by most high school students
when I was on the school board this was
giving in given in a high school and I
heard from my spies that the students
were taking this as a class project for
example how many times do we get drunk
married does your boyfriend hit you do
you take drugs etc etc some Weeks Later
a principal came to our school board
meeting with the disastrous results I
then informed him how the survey was
taken the student School Board member
verified this this other schools have
the same issues when they know the
survey is being taken social media goes
rampant with entries on how to answer
the questions also parents need to know
what their children are being asked
parental rights all questions on surveys
must be given to the parents which I
believe this bill does so they can make
decision to allow their child to take
the survey over the years we've heard
argument that parents do not get
permission slips from the survey of do
not opt in interesting parents have to
give an op in for field trips etc those
seem to be returned parents don't opt in
because they don't want the child to
take it also nowadays this is also being
done electronically emails Etc to
parents also sexual questions how many
high school students will answer they
are not sexually active do any any of
you remember when you were in high
school these surveys are a joke then
there are suicide question so let's put
the that in the St in the students Minds
also now some may testify to the survey
and others are all academic is the
schools responsible to teach not be
social workers also the
test test states that it is anonymous
the first seven questions can easily
show who the student is that if they
answer correctly and again students take
this as a joke a parent testified some
years ago stating that his son and
others stated that they were all 200 lb
black
females now it's been proven time out of
time that I mean remember the survey
done by the CDC and depending on what
administration has in power questions do
become political in the past there were
questions on guns in home now I bet
there will be questions on vaccinations
another argument that they need to Tire
school to take the survey to get the
full results what's the difference
student answering at a joke or not
answering at all and I remember an old
software engineer thing engineering
question garbage in garbage out I also
did statistics and what good is a
statistic if you don't have good results
you thank
you um any questions for representative
bom
see none thank you very much
you uh next is David Goldstein from the
association Chiefs of
police thank you for being here thank
youman and members of the committee is
this F no no press yeah there you go oh
there we go thank you very much by way
of introduction my name is David
Goldstein I am the recently retired
Chief from the city of Franklin uh I am
now uh working for the Rockham County
Sheriff's Office as a mental health and
wellness coordinator sworn in as a
deputy there um I've been a police
officer for over 46
years and I'm going to speak more to
bullet points than I am to a narrative
uh I have conducted and uh published
Empirical research uh survey research as
part of my academic life for both a
master's degree and for a PhD I'm here
representing the new Association of
chiefs of police and that I chair the uh
legislative committee we oppose hb44 uh
excuse me we oppose
446 446 excuse me uh as written this is
not my first appearance here to talk
about the yrbs and whereas the uh
Amendment seems to be more generic in
nature uh we certainly realize that it's
talking about specific issues as well um
we're a little bit confused as to why
there's such oppositions to learning as
much as we can about our children that's
our responsibility as parents and
contrary to what uh the sponsor just
testified to that was not our experience
in Franklin for example we found that
people were very serious about this um
it's a bonified effort quite frankly uh
in an e in order to learn about the
habits and beliefs and thoughts of our
children uh in his noninvasive way as
possible and frankly the the yrbs only
looks at six particular categor ories it
looks at behaviors that contribute to
unint unintentional injuries and
violence sexual behaviors of our
children that may contribute to
unintended pregnancies and sexually
transmitted diseases including HIV
Alcohol and Other Drug use tobacco use
unhealthy dietary behaviors and
inadequate physical activity all things
that we want our children to avoid if
they can and if we know more about it we
can certainly deal with that um this is
not a question of putting objection a
reading material into a school library
as seems to be happening throughout the
country we're actually doing this is
actually being conducted in a very uh
proper and uh specific way it's a
Bonafide effort to learn about the
habits and thoughts and beliefs of our
children in fact from a public health
point of view and I have a masters in
public health this is considered primary
prevention we want to know before the
diseases affect our children before the
behaviors affect our children we want to
know what's going on and that is how
Public Health Works if you looked at it
as if they were smoking we would try to
keep people from Ever picking up a
cigarette and then not have to worry
about the uh the uh results of that so
this is a similar type of thing to that
this is longitudinal type of research
there's no requirement in any way shape
or form that a student has to
participate and if is or her parents
don't want them to they don't have to
and the student doesn't even have to
answer the question it is strictly
voluntary the data however does assist
in in gathering evidence-based data uh
that we can use for such initiatives as
grants in the case of Franklin for
example in 2010 we initiated what we
call the U Franklin mayor drug task
force uh and this was aimed at drug use
among our students uh if you Mr C if you
could wrap up please uh yes sir uh just
to let you know that with that kind of
data the city of Franklin received
multi-million dollars in Grants over 15
years
we received drug free communities grants
which department which cities did not
get their first try and we did I would
merely ask that you think of it in terms
of what it's meant to do and I uh again
we ask you to it all this and I'm happy
to answer any questions you might have
thank you very much for being here uh
representative Dr thank you and thank
you for taking my question I've been
trying to find a lot of the answers that
of things that you've talked about yes
ma' can you tell me and I could not get
an answer to this how
how this survey helps direct money and
how who benefits does it go through DC
and the federal government are you
talking about the survey's money itself
or to use the survey for to use the
survey for again any Grant process
requires that we lay out in specificity
what we're going to do with the money
and what the grant is aimed at such as
our drug free communities Grant was in
Franklin we were able to do that uh it
is a very involved process and by having
this evidence based data we could show
that so many percentage of students
thought this versus so many percentage
of students thought that uh about these
six particular categories and that's how
we were able to toh receive those
funds yes another question I could not
find an answer for was uh we asked if
this was an opt out opt in instead of
opt out is there a certain number of
surveys like a a yeah exact threshold
that needs to be to be a Dependable
survey uh well there's the more you can
get the better in any survey research
quite frankly we understand that usually
around a third of the respondents is
what we're looking for to have any kind
of meaning whatsoever but we still
report the numbers as they come in uh as
far as opt-in versus opt out is
concerned I'm a parent I don't know how
many times I had to go through book bags
to find out what I was missing uh
because I was supposed to opt in and my
children for got to give me the note
from the teacher so to speak so this way
as an opt out uh it works a little bit
better and that also doesn't preclude
parents from going online if parents
want to know what the yrbs is and I did
this just before I came just to make
sure it's still valid I put yrbs in the
Google search line everything you want
to know is right there the numbers are
there the questions are there there's
nothing hidden in this this type of
thing but I'm not sure if that answers
your question but again the bottom line
is the more the better okay thank you
further questions represent Woodcock
thank you good afternoon sir thank you
for being here my pleasure um
recognizing that the sample size um
would diminish if it became an
opin um how imper is for the prevention
model to have the largest uh pool for
statistical research it's incredibly
imperative uh I'll give you an example
from my own survey research that I
conducted at the VA hospital in Boston
on uh veterans who were hospitalized who
had chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease and were continuing to smoke and
my hypothesis was uh is that in sense in
a very real sense self-destructive
Behavior you've been diagnosed with
empyema cancer what have you um and
using a survey and the what's as the
mmpi the Minnesota multiphasic inventory
which is a personality it has a subtest
I was able to show statistically that in
fact uh that is considered a
self-destruction so the more the better
again okay uh for preventative measures
and again Public Health looks at Prime
prevention in anywhere between three and
five levels the very simplest is three
primary prevention is stopping the
problem before it ever becomes a problem
don't smoke right period then you won't
get cancer emphas whatever and that's
what we're looking for
all thank you um in your in your um
program in Franklin your hometown um
was there post research done to validate
the the uh Grant actually uh yes we
continue we had to that was part of the
grant we also went so far as to go down
to Middle School uh in Franklin we took
it upon ourselves to do that and again
we got what we felt with some very
viable and legitimate responses thank
you thank you Mr chair repr represent
Freeman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming in front of us my pleasure
you you you made a comment and I can I
can definitely um relate to it about
when your kids were in school and you
had to fish around to the bottom of
their backpack to get the permission
slips I'm just curious why is this the
only only piece of information that
parents have to opt out of as opposed to
opt in when field trips even have to be
opted in on can do you you have any you
know any feelings or reasoning behind
that again as representative brought up
numbers would go down numbers would go
down with opt in versus opt down a
follow-up sir yes thank you um do you
have any empirical evidence of
that um right off the top of my head no
I just experience with it thank you R
Murray thank you Mr Sharon thank you for
taking my question I'm curious to know
whether or not um the aggregate data
that is is received you spoke with
respect to Franklin I understand that
but uh might the data um inform
decisions uh differently based on the
region of uh even the state of where
kids are based on lived
experiences you mean for example
geographically for example sure well
even socioeconomically I would never be
so bold to say that that wouldn't be a
contributing
factor further questions see none thank
Mr chairman committee members Aubrey
Friedman Bridgewater I speak in support
of this bill um most parents I think
everybody's heard about the the youth
Behavior whis you know the survey
everybody knows about it but to actually
open it up and look at the questions I
don't think that many parents have done
it sure you can go on on online and do
it I don't think they do it this bill
will make it so it's emailed to the
parents now that doesn't mean people
ignore emails people don't open emails
that could still happen but I do think
that a lot more people would actually
look at the questions and you know they
they're extremely nosy they're not as
bad as they used to be I've railed
against this particular survey for years
and actually in our own School District
they uh they just recently did it in the
Middle School there was I was railing
against it there in a Schoolboard
meeting and they had actually modified
it a little bit so the requirements of
this uh Bill are just that it's to be
emailed they probably already have an
email list for all the families so you
just type a little brief two or three
sentences you know here's the survey
we're going to do it in 10 days you
attach the survey and you hit send I
mean there's no Financial note to this
bill the administrative B would be
probably 10 minutes and You' sent it and
that's the end of it and the only my
only problem with this bill actually is
it doesn't have a penalty what happens
if the school district just doesn't do
it a bill has to have teeth in it and I
have seen several times in our own
School District new found that the
school board does not follow the law so
there should be some type of a penalty
and the bill is good the idea is good
but they do some school districts do not
comply with the law and there should be
teeth in it so um that's it I support
the bill with um some type of a penalty
or whatever because for to make the uh
parents or with taxpayers you have to go
to the MS budsman or the uh state board
you know uh you know Board of Education
to complain about it or the Attorney
General there should be teeth in the
bill and that's that's it I support the
Bill thank you thank you represent
Woodcock thank you uh thank you Mr fre
it's enjoyable to see you once again um
you always bring a perspective I love to
think about uh in the amendment you know
we're talking about the amendment right
okay um I haven't seen the amendment so
know do you understand this
requires written consent this is not
review it's not the parent sayings okay
this Rees written consent the email the
POR you were talking about sending out
to the parents we're going to do this um
is a nice advanced piece I got that but
to
participate the parent has to get back
and say yes so as if they're as busy as
you say they are and they may not have a
chance what happens to the the the data
for future St student prevention without
the parent opting without parent getting
back well if the parent doesn't get back
then the kid doesn't participate in the
survey and I consider that a good thing
that school should be for teaching and
not being for Gathering data so I
consider that a good thing actually that
Amendment thank you yep further
questions see none thank you very much
for thank you thank you being here for
this bill also thank you em miss vgy new
futures
good afternoon members of the committee
for the record my name is Emma savini
I'm the children's Behavioral Health
policy coordinator at new Futures new
Futures is a nonpartisan nonprofit
organization that solves problems
through policy change um we are here in
opposition to uh the amendment to House
Bill
446 um we have serious concerns about uh
the ability to collect viable data if
this survey were be were to be turned
into an optin model as opposed to an opt
out model um currently there are many
prevention programs mental health
programs um student support programs
that rely on yrbs data not only for
those uh important grants that you've
heard about today and will continue to
hear about um but also for just general
student wellness in schools a lot of
times schools will rely on ybs data to
ensure that students are allow are able
to have the support they need to be most
productive and most successful in their
academic careers um for instance
bullying is a really important um topic
of conversation these days and the ybs
is able to gather data on whether or not
students are facing violence in schools
or feel safe in their schools um when
students feel safe they're able to
succeed academically the most it also uh
asks is about um mental health of
students which is really important to be
able to understand how students are
doing and again able to contribute to
their academic
success um I'll also just note that the
ybs data is completely Anonymous and
completely voluntary there is data to
show that students do take this survey
seriously um year over-year the data is
collected um it's analyzed and compared
compared to previous years so that we're
able to see Trends and those Trends are
able to indicate that the data is valid
and reliable year-over-year so while you
may have a student here or there not
take this survey seriously students do
generally take this survey very
seriously and actually appreciate the
opportunity to use it as a tool to ask
for help when they need
it um and I will finally just clarify my
written testimony is going around but
also the testimony from one of our
Advocates um who works at the do Police
Department um is also um circulating and
they were unfortunately unable to make
it today but wanted to share their
perspective as well um I'll close and uh
questions does anyone else who need a
copy of the
representative
dry thank you and maybe you're the qu
person to ask this question of as well
um still trying to get a handle on what
you think the difference would be if
this is so popular with the students if
they had to opt in rather than opt out
what is is there a threshold of number
of responses that you have to get in
order to make a good data reliable
survey I am not a data person so I don't
have that number off the top of my head
I believe there are better people better
equipped in the audience to answer that
question sorry I can't get it to you
okay follow follow up yes okay do you
thank you then maybe a philosophical
question how does the
Data Drive money for Grants and things
like that how is that tied together so
with um as Chief Goldstein mentioned
grants both federal state and private
grants almost across the board need
Baseline and Trend data to determine one
where your starting point is and then is
the thing you're trying to implement
working is the are the grant dollars
being used effectively so you in order
to get the Grant have to show that there
is a need using that Baseline data from
the ybs in this instance and then to
show that you were effectively using
those Grant dollars and may be applying
for additional Grant dollars um to
continue your program have to show that
the trend is in your favor using the ybs
data over several years um this survey
is given every two years so we have um
pretty good continuous data to show that
okay in year one students were really
having a problem with bullying on campus
they weren't feeling safe we implemented
an anti-bullying campaign using Grant
dollars and now in year four we're
seeing that more students are reporting
that they're feeling safe on campus and
feeling prepared to learn and succeed
academically because of that so the
grant dollars were used
effectively thank you further questions
represent
kuger thank you Mr chair I just wanted
to try to understand so would that data
then come back to school administrators
so you would see the results within that
school district not just a Statewide
data yes I believe the data is broken
out by um County in New Hampshire and
then um perhaps the department would be
better equipped to answer the nuances of
exactly who has access um to school and
District level level data but my
understanding is that the data is
aggregated specifically to can keep
anonymity of the uh respondents thank
you rent
Freeman thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question do you know how
many years this survey has been
administered in New Hampshire um in New
Hampshire I don't know the number off
the top of my head um but I do know that
the survey has been administered um
nationally and I believe New Hampshire
has been a participant for several
decades at at this
point follow several decades at 70
years several several several Dees not
seven sorry I have a cold so I might not
be most understandable
today thank where woodcock
thank you Mr chair um thank you for for
being here um have you have a CH have
you had this a followup question coming
have you had a chance to look at the
amendment I have yes thank you so if I
may see the part that um first all I
think the ybs I think it's critical uh
having been a health teacher I think
it's without question critical but the
intent of the amendment in my mind seems
to have changed drastically where
initially the they was emailing
notification and opt in uh if we look at
line uh 16 and 17 as I read this it says
that the parents must send such surveys
through the email so that suggests to me
that that survey not may or may not be
filled out by the student this is not an
opt-in opt out if you look at 1617 this
now requires the survey in itself to be
sent to the parent do you read it that
same way
that's an interesting reading I hadn't
read it that way but I I now that I you
say it I do believe that is a a
potential reading it could be a problem
May fa thank it doesn't say permission
to take it says send the survey I can't
think of any survey we're trying or
anything we trying reliable adult or
reliable data by sending it out in
advance um to to a different group
that's taking the
survey thank you Mr chair Murray
[Music]
yes uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my questions I am curious I I
I don't want to speak to the uh sponsors
intent I think there might be a typo in
there um to some degree but I am curious
what should happen in the event that a
parent or Guardian does not have email
um because it says that they shall do it
through email and other so is that the
first step and then if somebody does not
receive it how what
then is that a requirement so sorry no
so I didn't mean to cut you off thank
you for your question I um it's my
understanding that as I read it this
would include both email and any
additional means of delivery the
district deems appropriate so I don't
know who would be making that
determination I assume the school board
and I don't know how that determination
would be made so that's a bit vague I
also know that there are lots of schools
who have transitioned to an app as a
common way of communicating with parents
which is not necessarily noted in this
so it might make it confusing for
parents who are typically looking at an
app to communicate with the teacher and
then they're getting emails about this
so that also May create some like Lost
issues follow up thank you and the
questions correct me if I'm wrong the
questions are already required to be on
the district website is that correct
further questions seeing none thank you
very much thank
Hawkins good afternoon thank you for the
opportunity to testify today for the
record my name is Sam Hawkins uh I'm
here today representing Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness uh in opposition to any
amendments that would make uh the ybs
and opt in uh to be clear we do fully
believe that parents should receive
notice of non-academic surveys they
should have the ability to review their
contents and they should have the choice
to opt their student out but we are
opposed to the policies that would make
the survey an opt in for the simple
reason that busy parents may miss the
notice regarding the yrbs due to their
busy lives uh disallowing their children
to participate even if the parent would
otherwise actually encourage that
participation um you've heard and we
also believe that this opt-in
requirement will make it nearly
impossible to obtain uh statistically
valid results which will hinder the
state's uh prevention intervention and
postvention efforts uh I want to take
more time to address a concern that is
often raised surrounding the ybs and
that is that asking youth about their
mental health asking youth about suicide
will contribute to those very same
negative mental health outcomes we
firmly uh disagree with this position
and believe that that position is rooted
in the same stigma surrounding mental
health and suicide that has for so long
uh led to people not seeking the care
they need we instead believe that when
we openly and responsibly speak about
mental health and suicide we can
eliminate that stigma and encourage all
people to reach out and ask for help it
is in this way that the ybs can actually
be a valuable tool it can open up honest
conversations about mental health and
suicide for youth so they can feel
comfortable going to their family and
speaking about the help they need um I
would just say that um uh if you hear of
any perceived or anecdotal increase in
negative mental health outcomes or
suicidality following someone taking the
ybs I would not say that it is the ybs
causing that but rather it is uh that
elimination of stigma that opening of
the conversation that is encouraging
that student to talk about the
challenges they are facing and I also
want to go back and say that again uh
just because a child is not opted out
doesn't mean they have to take it if
they have an emotional response to a
question they can stop at any time uh in
closing I just want to emphasize again
that the wire RBS is safe it doesn't
encourage risky Behavior or contribute
to negative mental health outcomes for
Youth and it's crucial for our state as
such the quality of the results must be
maintained and I thank you for your time
thank you very much representative
Dr thank you maybe you are the quite
person to ask about this because I'm
still trying to get a hand on the
statistically valid uh parts of it you
said it would be nearly impossible to
get statistically valued results what's
the threshold that you're looking for do
you have a a ballpark a number I I
apologize I'm I'm a liberal arts student
not a data Wiz I'm going to Kick the Can
to the department and hopefully they are
able to answer that question for you but
I do think it's a valuable question
thank you thank you represent represent
Murray uh thank you Mr Shon thanks for
taking my question um mental health is
such an important component of what we
um what we do here as a a group of
legislators for a myriad of different
areas of public policy so one of the my
questions to you is whether or not um
data over time would also help um shape
mental health initiatives in uh
counties through mental health services
at your local or Regional Mental Health
Centers yeah thank you for the question
I think um data is incredibly valuable
in all the ways we try and bolster the
state's um prevention intervention
postvention efforts I mean I've filled
out a couple grants in my my time a
question you see on practically every
Grant even the easiest Grant is what is
the need what problem are we solving uh
it's great to be able to say here's what
we see at a national level it's even
better to say here's what we're seeing
at the local level not just at the state
in the county um and even beyond that I
yes absolutely I think organizations
providers can use that data to get
grants to uh go to funders to seek
funding for their services but I think
also it's a valuable tool for the
legislature for people to come in front
of all of you be able to say here's this
great thing you did a couple years ago
and here's we're actually seeing these
numbers go down or here's where we need
to maybe adjust what we did um so I
think it's valuable in many ways thank
you follow up quickly please thank you
um and with regard to early intervention
um getting ahead of costly expenses is
is there any value to the data being
collected now uh to get ahead of an
issue that might be developing yeah I um
I think that's sort of uh complex in
that the way there will be um youth who
are sort of at all stages of um their
mental health Journey if they're facing
mental health challenges um but I do
think one thing we strongly believe is
that when people get the care they need
in their community at the time that they
need it we avoid crisis you know every
day there are kids waiting in the
emergency department for inpatient care
if that child feels comfortable um and
encouraged to open up about a maybe less
severe um Mental Health Challenge um
before it reaches a crisis Point um I
think that that could decrease uh the
higher Acuity of care that we are seeing
being utilized thank you R
LF thank you Mr chairman I just wanted
to ask you are we discussing the
benefits or negatives of the youth risk
behavior survey or are we discussing the
um I I think that the uh we're
discussing the the amendment um but uh
the need um for opt in versus opt out I
think is a valid question thank
you represent Freeman did you have a
question I did thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question so
after a student complain and and I know
you'll answer this to the best of your
ability after a student completes a
survey and that student may express some
severe
suicidality how does that information
get passed on to a person that would be
able to address that immediately with
the
survey I appreciate the question um uh I
think what you're getting at um is is an
important issue and it's sort of
balancing the key priorities of we all
agree that this survey should be
anonymous we also agree that kids uh who
are in Mental Health crisis need help as
soon as possible um I think it would
undermine the important Anon anonymity
of the survey to have a pipeline where
if someone answers a certain question a
certain way they are then linked to
resources but I do think that is why we
need to build up Community Resources in
the school in the community at large
that are reaching out early thank you
yes represent morrris thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question kind of
a piggyback off hers and with what you
just said representative Freeman sorry
um you mentioned that you'd be looking
to get the individual support but if
it's so Anonymous then how exactly would
that work right uh thank you for your
question um again the ybs is not a
screening tool um well I mean it is a
survey in the way that we are trying to
gather data about where our youth are at
it is not a diagnostic clinical
screening Tool uh that is intended to
immediately get people into treatment
but what we do know uh as an
organization is that uh and this is
really just a core tenant of um suicide
prevention is having those open
questions encourages people to seek help
just being asked that question of are
you feeling sad or hopeless are you
feeling
suicidal that will encourage people to
go to their parents to have those
conversations to seek help if they need
it so while there is not a uh direct
link from you answer this to get into
treatment I do think there is um a
culture around having these
conversations that does connect people
to the care they need and we've heard
that from our families our members um
I've seen it in my personal life thank
you follow up quickly I I got like a
million questions so I'm trying to kind
of narrow in here so where exactly does
the money come from for the grants when
the data is
collected uh thank you for your question
uh could you clarify what Grant
specifically you're talking about I
would say any and all sure I mean uh
grants can come from uh the state they
can come nationally they can come from
private funders um really anyone that
has an interest in specific programs
that they would like to fund they will
put out grants um that uh people can
apply for service providers
organizations can apply for um really
money Woodcock thank you good afternoon
thank you for being here I know it's not
easy afternoon um going back to the uh
aggregate data that you're implying that
we don't disaggregate by individual uh
uh person because that's not the intent
they nullify inent am I correct to
believe that the school systems get a
result of the agre data at the end uh
thank you for your question uh just of
clarification are you asking whether the
School receives school specific
information or student specific
information school specific
May yes scho school specific I I would
uh defer to the department on that one
I'm not sure whether it's broken out at
a school level okay you thank you thank
you very much for your testimony thank
you um Miss o Higgins and Rogers from
the Department of Health and Human
Services what I
asked but you know in that
to
know thought school I thought our school
school
she said
she hi good afternoon we're going to ask
our colleague will moer to join us as
well if that's okay he's not on our pink
card thank you um could you what was the
last name we'll add that to the card
r good afternoon thank you so much for
having us I'm for the record I'm Jenny O
Higgins I'm the legislative liaison and
Senior policy analyst for Behavior
Health at
DHHS hi good afternoon I'm Abby Rogers
I'm the legislative lison for the
Services and I'm William Moyer I'm the
section administrator for the health
statistics and data management section
at Department of Public Health and so I
do have the answer to the questions
about um what we need to make what CDC
needs to have the surveys be
representative and the short answer is
0% but the longer answer is that so the
ybs is typically offered to all public
high school students from that CDC
selects a sample of the schools
classrooms and students from which they
can make a representative
sample the CDC will only consider the
sample to be sufficiently representative
if one of two criteria are met the first
criteria is an overall response rate of
60% which is basically they look at the
number of schools that participate out
of the number of schools that they
sample multipli by the number of
students that that participated in have
valid surveys out of the number of
students that were
sampled however starting in 2021 CDC um
made another criteria in response to
dropping participation rates which was
resulting in many um States or other
localities not being able to get
representative results which means that
they couldn't get any of the survey data
back if I could just ask you to move the
mic a little closer yeah thank
you so second criteria is a non-response
bias analysis which essentially is they
will compare the um students who
participated with those who did not now
because they can't compare them on the
results of Interest they can they
compare them on things such as for the
schools the enrollment size if it's a
small medium or large school a poverty
measure which is usually the percentage
of students with free or reduced lunch
and the local type which would be Urban
Suburban or Rural and then look at the
students and look at their the sex grade
and race and race and ethnicity if
responders and non-responders are
similar in all those categories CDC will
say that the survey is still
representative and they will be able to
give you back
results um what I can also say is that
so for 2021 and 2023 in New Hampshire
our overall response rate was just
around 65% so we did meet the criteria
but we were not that high above it um
and in terms of
um the effect of opt in versus opt out I
can say that in New Jersey they have an
opt in and in 2015 and 2017 they did not
meet the 60% criteria so New Jersey did
not get any ybs data for those years in
2019 and 2021 they also did not meet the
criteria in 2019 they had an overall
response rate of 49% in 2021 they had an
overall response rate of
26% however due to the non-response bias
CDC did determine that the results were
representative enough to give them
uh could do you want to we'll do it
individually in terms of questions if
that is it okay represent dry thank you
so another statistical question these
are like weighted than the weighted
values for this
Statistics yeah so for the
representative sample they basically use
the principles the CDC uses principles
of survey design to wait each response
so that when you when they analyze it
the results can be
you can infer from those results to the
overall population of high school
students in New Hampshire follow follow
so I just looked at the chart of the
since like since 1991 and the the amount
that's been weighted has gone from 36%
to
97.8% do you can you account for that um
I don't not I'm not understanding okay
so on the Y RBS website it talks about
the percent of the data that they wait
and it's gone from 30 6% that they do to
90 almost 99% in the last two tests and
I'm just wondering are they waiting are
we getting less data and they're waiting
more
things um You probably have to review it
yeah I think I would have to review that
okay I'd be happy to go into it thank
you any further questions yes repres
Morris thank you Mr chair thanks for
thaning my question you just mentioned
earlier that New Jersey didn't um get
enough statistics to get the data back
so what happened from
that yeah so for 2015 and 2017 if you go
to their website where they give all the
reports there's nothing for those
years U so there may be nothing for
those years but what exactly does that
mean in essence I like what what were
the consequences yes thanks sure so I
can speak to how New Hampshire uses the
data and so how that would impact us to
not have the statistical information
like New Jersey as an example so because
the youth risk behavior survey is the
most reliable and valid data set that we
have um in Behavioral Health we use the
data to secure grants including our
state opioid response Grant um our
Substance Abuse Prevention block grants
many other prevention treatment recovery
funding that help us to address
substance misuse in New Hampshire we
also utilize the funding to track
progress on the state's goals so how the
the um children's system of care the
tenure Mental Health Plan how our
community mental health centers and
Regional public health networks are
responding to the needs of Youth in our
state we use it for our Suicide
Prevention plan and annual report we um
use it for the Governor's Commission on
Alcohol and Other Drugs action plan it's
really the way that we both are able to
to ask for funding for need it's the way
that we're able to flexibly respond to
the to to have an understanding of the
of Youth that are obviously Ever
Changing um and then it's a way for us
to also track our progress our outcomes
time further questions see none um did
you oh I'm sorry represent Freeman
that's okay thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question how many years
has this survey been given in New
Hampshire since 1993 thank you so we
have additional statements just taking I
was I didn't know if you wanted to move
on to miss Roger so I just talked a
little bit about the some of the ways
that we use this fun this um information
and Behavioral Health um so it the
opt-in in particular would be to have
these devastating consequences to us in
behavioral health because it would
reduce the participation and because we
it allows us to better understand and
response to the needs of the youth
population um so the with Behavioral
Health much of the many mental health
conditions and substance use disorder
can start in adolescence but they're
Progressive illnesses and so if the
earlier that we are able to identify a
need and have intervention and begin
treatment the better the health outcomes
for these young people so it's
critically important that we have an
understanding of what are the needs of
our youth population so that we can
adapt our programming and our prevention
to address those directly um the good
news is that these are treatable and
preventable challenges but we have to
know what's going on on the ground um so
we have to understand where we should
invest and how to monitor the population
level outcomes over time so again not
individual outcomes but understanding in
these grade levels how is this changing
over time and so that we can respond to
those needs we also have youth who use
this information themselves and are able
to do peer-to-peer um intervention and
prevention within their school Community
by understanding the social Norm forms
and by promoting uh healthy and positive
behaviors and so we know that we heard a
little bit about earlier um about The
credibility of the data and do youth
take this seriously you'll probably hear
from a number of Youth groups here today
um that are working directly with young
people and I myself was a youth services
director for 15 years and so the youth
are actively using the data themselves
and the research tells us that this data
can be gathered from adolescence just as
credibly as it can from adults
and the the ybs does go through
reliability checks to help identify the
small percentage of students who may
falsify answers so if that happens there
are uh an ways to reduce that um and the
other piece around that I wanted to
address was some questions around sort
of planting the idea in children's heads
when we ask questions about mental
health and substance use and things like
that and there is no evidence that
simply asking students about health
behaviors would encourage them to try
that behavior in fact in suicide
prevention I'm also uh certified in
National evidence-based Suicide
Prevention and we actually train people
to ask the question because it's often
met with a sense of relief so um it can
reduce the burden of carrying something
scary or challenging alone and allow
people to feel young people to feel seen
and respected uh so that they you know
when we ask young people about their
mental health we don't teach them to be
unwell we actually learn the most they
actually learn the most critical step of
taking care of ourselves which is being
able to talk about it just like we would
for every other health issue um so this
is allowing us to both reduce the shame
and stigma and open the door for finding
healthy um can take a few questions
questions yeah sure represent
Murray uh thank you for taking my
question thank you um to the department
for um taking my question do you know
the
percentages of um
programs who receive grants of all kinds
State local Federal um and how that
moving to an opt-in may impact those
programs do you have any data about
roughly how many programs receive grants
it yeah I mean we utilize the block
grant funding the state opioid response
grant funding that the funding that I
was mentioning in those opening remarks
in a number of ways in community and so
it would it would take a while to
catalog the ways that that funding is
being utilized today the state op
response Grant alone is $56
million um the other piece I just wanted
to mention is around um the the schools
being you know utilized for academics
and just the Deep Impact that mental
health has on academic performance and
so having an understanding of this
information is critical to high
performing schools in particular so
mental health problems can affect a
student you know energy level their
concentration
um and their optimism and it hinders
their performance so there's a direct
correlation here to addressing
Behavioral Health and um having having
mental health challenges can you know is
associated with lower grade point
averages and lower test scores and lower
engagement and and um attainment in
general in academics um I had a question
um you mentioned about data is been used
in schools by youth in the school um how
is data from the surveys filtered by
school to provide to that school or
School District do you want to speak to
that more
specifically yeah so often I think
students will use either the Statewide
results or also we provide reports that
are by Public Health Region um and this
reminds me that in terms of what the
schools get we do provide reports back
to the superintendent that gives results
for their school this is not the
representative results it's just results
aggregate results for all the students
have the each school that took it for
those reports we will suppress if it's
small numbers I believe it's there has
to be at least 20 students for each
question we give if there's less than
that we'll suppress the results to
protect the privacy and confidentiality
and then it's up to the superintendent
whether they would release those reports
to students or anyone else or just keep
them for themselves um if you could
repeat the number um that you used to um
filter the um privacy I believe it's 20
but I'm not I don't remember exactly
that but it's somewhere around there
thank you morrris thank you Mr chair
thanks for taking my question uh so some
of the grants that are mentioned earlier
is this more for Community Based or more
like in school I guess I could try to
elaborate more um like grants for Mental
Health Counselors to be brought into the
schools the funding the funding that has
been mentioned is used in a variety of
ways it's also that the department is
not the only the Department of Health
and Human Services is not the only state
holder utilizing the results so you'll
hear from local coalitions youth groups
that are utilizing ybs data for their
region to understand what the needs are
in their locality and apply for
additional grants that may be through
philanthropy or some other not you know
not federal to State funding which is
what I was speaking to um they'll
they're also the Department of Education
is using them in in order order to the
results as well in order to address
needs within their school that might be
other forms of federal uh funding that I
did not
mention we Woodcock thank you chairman
good afternoon and and I just want I
wasn't clear sir on it wasn't you it was
me I couldn't hear right um I just want
to make sure I'm
clear you said that the
data um for each school or school
system would be disaggregated to the
extent that the super make clear that
the superintendent at least have an
overview of how his school responded how
is that correct before that was
different from we heard earlier in the
conversation not from you from another
person that's correct we provide the
aggregate reports fact to the
superintendent before each School follow
yes thank you and I I appreciate that
because we heard something different
before that was the point I was trying
to get to um since you're using a uh if
I'm wrong stop me I think you said a
minimum 60% response rate so if we have
the response rate the superintendent
gets it is it would seem to me that this
this particular survey the ybs is
critical because that allows that school
to say you know what we can see a trend
in what's changing in our school perhaps
we should supplement services in this
area or that area or would that be a
fair guesstimation from my part I
believe so one corre is that the 60% is
for the overall Statewide and Public
Health Region results which are
representative the school reports are
not weighted so it's just the students
that took the survey that day so okay
the big caveat is that it may or may not
be representative if a school has a high
response rate then it probably is
representative but if a school has a
very low response rate then obious stay
thank you so much thanks uh jman yeah if
I if I could follow up um how do you
identify the school is that um an entry
on the survey that's
completed yes okay thank you
uh rent Freeman did you have a question
I did thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I I have heard
a lot of talk about how if we get um
below the 60% threshold that could
affect our government it will affect our
government grants and I've heard a lot
of testimony today about how if this
optin is adopted that will absolutely
impact it I I need to get some Imperial
empirical evidence to prove that do you
have anything that
would solidify those concerns I we can
all we can all agree that those programs
are crucial they're extremely important
we can all agree on that we can also
agree that this bill does not take the
ybs out of school systems all this does
is allow parents to opt in so I I kind
of I I kind of want to don't want want
to put the cart before the horse as far
as saying we're going to lose all of
this if we put this often because
parents AR going to answer this I have a
little more faith in the parents so
could you give me some evidence to prove
that in fact the numbers will go down
yes thank you so much for the question
so what we know is that we in New
Hampshire are not much higher than the
60% threshold so because we're close to
that line if we have any reduction in
data we won we will um you know not make
for more accurate data but simply less
data and if we H if we don't meet the
60% % threshold we will be at risk for
not understanding this these the needs
of our youth not being able to monitor
the outcomes over time and the funding
reduction or H is a potential as well so
I think it's the the if we were
collecting today yrbs at a 95% threshold
or something it might be less concerning
I think the reason that we are are so
concerned is that if any reduction in
what we collect today puts us very close
to that 60% threshold know if my
colleagues
TR thank you um thank you for taking the
question let me just ask so the 65% that
New Hampshire is at right now that's
with everyone
opting out from it so are we saying 35%
opt
out
sorry sorry so I'll already schools are
given the opportunity to participate in
the survey so the the schools need to
opt in and then parents are given the
opportunity to opt out and then students
can also choose not to take the survey
or not to answer any questions so
there's multiple layers of of opting you
know into the survey now both by
District family and individual and to
the actual percentage of those that
answer yeah so I can say that um let's
see so far 2023 it was 84% of the
schools participated and then of those
76% of the students participated which
creates the overall response rate of
64% and in addition student responses
will not be counted if they um
essentially CDC will do certain checks
to see if they're doing something like
just giving the same answer for
everything those responses will also be
thrown out so the you know the worst of
the if a student's really not taking it
R Woodcock I appreciate your patience R
Cordell um so going if I may go back to
your comment for represent if 35% you
talk about the lay opt out but you said
84% so of the school systems in New
Hampshire participated so does that mean
then I'm just trying to make sure I'm
clear that the 16% of those school
systems that did not participate chose
for for their group not participate so
the local loc local government the local
school boards the local parents made
that choice and the school board said
okay we won is that basically what we're
saying yes thank
you um Mr Rogers did you have comments
also I have just a b everything's been
so well covered I don't have much to to
add other than to try to answer
representative J's question about the
weight The Waiting um so to give an
example the weight is the number of
states that have representative data so
if for example if 26 States participated
uh in the ybs only and only nine meant
the participate the participation rate
to be able to get the weighted uh
results so for example in 2023 39 States
participated in the ybs and 36 States me
the participation rate so the percent
weighted is 92.3 if that makes sense say
that one more time okay read the last
yes in 2023 for example 39 States
participated in the ybs and 36 only 36
meant the participation rate so that
percent is rated to come out to 92.3% on
the website okay and the only other
thing I I did want to add my colleagues
have covered everything so well is you
know if if a um if the ybs would be you
know would be an opt out um the burden
on schools to follow up with parents to
call parents to try to get that
participation rate up and follow up and
and make sure that people are aware that
the survey is being given um you know
there there would be an Administration
burden to try to raise it get to get
that participation rate up so that's
just something to consider thank you
repres Noble thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um is
it possible for us to see the
District I think we'd have to get back
to you on that the superintendant all
are given their data what we publish is
Statewide data and by Regional public
Health Network okay so you would be able
to see it within region but not Town
specific thank
you thank you very much just wanted to
be for the record we we do have we are
opposed to the amendment just I don't
think we said that thank
yeah
I'll
set so good afternoon um chairman and
honorable members of the committee my
name is Jennifer Chisum and I am the
executive director of the New Hampshire
coalition to end homelessness um and so
I decided to come up to testify as an
agency who very um much so is looking
forward to using some yrbs data um so
one of the flagship products I guess of
the the New Hampshire Coalition is our
state of homelessness uh in New
Hampshire report um hopefully everybody
has gotten one in their mailbox and has
seen it um and so we analyze data to
track Trends on homelessness in the
state um and so in 2021 y RBS added a
question about um housing status that
we're very much looking forward to to
using as I said um in our next report um
youth homelessness is tremendously
difficult to count notor iously so um
and so we're just concerned that
anything that we do that's going to put
um data at risk for us to be able to
tell the true Narrative of what's
Happening across the state with youth
experiencing homelessness um it you know
scares us especially hearing that many
of our districts are so close to that
participation rate um so we I am not a
you know data expert um we contract with
New Hampshire um fiscal policy Institute
to do our data crunching um and so I do
know that there have been data points
that haven't been able to use that I've
love I would love to talk about um but
it just was found not to be
representative that there wasn't enough
data um to be able to use it um and so
with the difficulties of tracking youth
homelessness um we already know it's a
huge issue in the state so um in our
report from this year um I can tell you
that from 2022 to 2023 the number of
people in families experiencing
homelessness in New Hampshire uh
increased by 40% um and that's both in
the point and time data which is a one
24hour count on a very cold day in
January um as well as the um entire year
we also have calendar year data um and
then children under the age of 18
represented one out of every five five
people experiencing homelessness in the
state during that time um and so
because when I talk about our data I
talk about you know who's in the data
but who are we also missing and so our
data is based on the HUD definition of
homelessness which is very specific and
very narrow um it talks to people who
are um in a program meant to House
people experiencing homelessness um or
somebody who is um staying in someplace
not meant for human habitation so your
car attent um the abandoned basement um
and something like that what it doesn't
count um is all people in New Hampshire
who are doubled up so staying with
family staying with friends because they
have had some sort of um issue economic
issue maybe lost a job lost a partner um
you know were evicted because their
landlord decided to renovate uh those
sorts of things and are now staying in
someplace temporarily um and so this is
where we see a huge number of Youth and
it is such a hard number to get at so as
I said in yrbs they added a question
that very specifically ask about that
giving the option to let us know that
that is their situation um and so you
know we do have Counts from the school
districts that we look at um that they
use this expanded mckin vento Act
definition of of homelessness that
includes families and individuals who
are doubled up um students who are
doubled up um um but trying to count
this number is near impossible and so
any kind of defin or any kind of
information that we can get um that's
going to guide us to be able again to
tell The Narrative of what's truly going
on with our children with our youth with
our students um is going to help us as
an agency publish the data which um
speaking to how does this data get used
um so this is a go-to document for not
only the state of New Hampshire
municipalities for homeless service
providers to be able to use the data um
and talk about the trend
uh in order to apply for Grants and
bring money into the state so for
example um the youth homelessness
demonstration program money from HUD um
you know these the data from this um
would be able to support bringing more
money into the state for that to support
our kids um and so um I think that
that's where where I'll kind of end it I
don't need to read my whole testimony
other than to say that the data truly
drives our ability to support what we
need for our kids and to bring money
into the state um and to be able to talk
about it effectively um and this is data
that I don't want to lose I don't want
to lose it because there's no other way
for me to get it um and to talk about it
in in a in a reliable way and I will say
um that there is a question you know
people have questioned RI reliability I
can understand that I'm a duly licensed
mental health and um drug and alcohol um
clinician uh kind of in in my past life
before I got into systems work um and so
I've worked for over a decade with
adolescence um with mental health
concerns conerns who were experiencing
homelessness who were using substances
so I get where that's coming from but
NIH um tested the reliability of the
yrbs the 2021 um yrbs and found that 90%
96% of the data in a test retest
situation um was at least moderately
moderately um reliable for retest and
that
73% um was either um substantially or
perfectly reliable um and so that we're
looking at something that NIH is saying
like yes is good data um I don't want to
you
questions yes R I'm
sorry I was not writing fast enough you
said 96% was moderately reliable and um
yep and
73% uh was found to be substantially um
or almost perfectly reliable thank you
repres Morse uh thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question so I I do see
where you're coming from with uh the
necessity for the homeless information
what I'm struggling to wrap my head
around would be one of the questions on
Firearms within the home so parents who
don't want let's say that made
information that could be somehow
brought back to them and I know there's
been controversy on the anonymous
aspects of it um how would let's say a
question revolving around Firearms with
a home be more beneficial data
collection um so you know a Firearms is
not not something that I can speak
specifically to however it is is my
understanding I'll back go back to the
fact that um from my understanding of
the survey it is anonymous so that it um
gets us good information while
maintaining family privacy on all of the
issues that are are being discussed
within it you know so homelessness in
and of itself also carries a stigma um
you know parents often times either
don't know that they um qualifi and
students themselves don't know that they
qualify under the definition of
homelessness and so don't know to say
anything to ask for help ask for um
Services um and you know and also
there's that stigma because sometimes
there's a fear I don't want dcyf in my
home um you know so I think that from my
understanding the survey is designed um
to protect that s the survey data in
that there are a lot of questions that
people would show concern about
potentially um so and I understand that
privacy concern thank you ruption of um
Murray thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question again with the
requiring of the optin versus opt out um
modality um is there a potential for as
missing key indicators around what are
called Aces or adverse childhood
experiences in addition to that um I
know I and I that maybe this question is
more appropriate for the Department I
can follow up later but in the event
that there is some sort of disaster
where like a debart team is like
dispatched into communities or towns and
that could possibly impact that
Community for years coming would this
impact the ability to be able to help
those communities over a longterm
trajectory Shar I'll put on my clinical
hat for a minute um is somebody who's um
trained in tfcbt which is trauma focused
cognitive behavioral therapy and have
done a lot of work with adolescence um
Aces if people don't know it's the
adverse childhood um events study which
shows that um a series of I think it's
maybe 11 different things is just so
impactful on people that can happen to
them when they're kids and it affects
not only mental health but also physical
health outcomes as adults um and it's
extremely powerful data um and so I
would say absolutely yes you know the
things that you were asking about in the
ybs um all kind of play to some of the
the aces um that you're talking about
here um and so as a prevention tool to
like again truly know The Narrative of
what's going on with our kids um you
know I'll say anecdotally in in my
substance Ed sort of work like I can
think of a 14-year-old that was
injecting opiates um you know that Mom
didn't know the school didn't know um
and so you know is this a place for her
privately to have been able to say like
this is something that's going on with
me um and and to kind of tell that story
like you know like let's give the kids
the opportunity um to be able to share
what's what's going on um and so I think
I missed the second part of your
question but debart um so debart is a
wonderful debriefing tool for any a
place that's had you know a traumatic
incident um you know therapist will come
just okay yeah and so I would say that
again just as much data as we can get um
to be able to know what's going on in
those communities and what the needs are
because if you have the the the best
data that you can looking at a community
um to to know what their needs are
bringing in the debart team or whatever
it might be for for those communities so
thank you for the question Woodcock
thank you um when you started talk about
the reliability index with 90% And 73%
you quoted where it came from I think I
said did you say nhi um NIH can you tell
us what that e means I apologize so it's
the National Institute of Health thank
you thank you
chair see no further questions thank you
BL thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'm Melissa blasik I am here
representing rebuild NH I'm here to
speak in support of the amendment to HP
446 which seeks to require parental
consent for the CDCC risk behavior
survey the protection of pupil Rights
Act of 1978 prohibits schools from
asking about the following number one
political affiliation or beliefs of
students or their family two mental or
psychological problems of the child or
their family three sex Behavior or
attitudes four students illegal
antisocial demeaning or
self-incriminating behavior five
critical appr appraisals of a child's
family members six privileged
Communications between a student and a
therapist religious leader or lawyer
seven student or family's religious
beliefs or practices and eight family
income however despite these protections
the CDC risk behav Behavior survey still
asks all these questions that could
violate these very principles the courts
have ruled that such surveys are legal
as long as they are voluntary but we
must ask ourselves is a survey really
voluntary if the parent who has the
ultimate authority over the child's
well-being has not given consent
moreover there's an argument that this
lack of affirmative parental consent
could be a violation of New Hampshire
Constitution specifically article 2B
which guarantees the right to privacy
and protection from government intrusion
parents Safeguard their children's
rights including the right to privacy
until they reach adulthood and it should
be their decisions and not the
government's whether personal
information is shared I understand that
there are concerns about Federal funding
and the potential impacts of this
amendment however we must not Overlook
the fact that the state could be
treading on thin legal ground by
allowing surveys that may not be as
voluntary as they
appear at what point do we draw the line
between voluntary participation and
government overreach into the lives of
our children the amendment to HB 446
simply ensures that parents par have the
ability to make an informed decision
regarding their children's participation
in the survey I urge you to support this
questions representative Morris thank
you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question so I only have one so far and
um if one or more of these questions
trigger something in students is there
anyone equipped to handle the situation
on site uh thank you for the question
that is not my area of expertise I I
don't affirmatively know the answer to
that
question represent
TR thank you thank you foring taking my
question if if these are
anonymous questions does this still
apply does that principle or that
protection still apply thank you for the
question yes it does um because the
child is still sharing those things
yes R Cornell thank you Mr chair I
didn't catch at the beginning when you
listed the things what what were you
listing the protection of pupil's Rights
Act of
1978 and that is still in effect that's
New Hampshire's no that's a federal
law so followup yes in the 32 years that
this um survey has been given has there
been any complaints or any follow up or
any laws that have been broken by this I
certainly know plenty appearance who
complained yes I don't know any who have
pursued legal action but also understand
it takes a certain type of person to go
through and get a lawyer and start suing
the state I mean those kind of people
don't necessarily come around all the
time um but it doesn't mean that the
there rer Freeman quick question very
quick thank you very much thank you for
taking my question so what you're saying
is that this protection of pupil rights
from 1978 applies only if filling out
the questionnaire isn't voluntary is
that
correct understanding that opt out is
technically not voluntary but opt in is
that is my opinion thank
you thank you very much for being
Downey sorry that's for the next bill
for the amendment oh okay y
you good afternoon uh thank you chairman
and members of the committee my name is
Ashley wheeler um I am here representing
the straford county regional Public
Health Network um I am a public health
professional I am a certified prevention
specialist I'm also a uh certified
Suicide Prevention trainer as well so um
I just want wanted to start by answering
um a question from representative Morse
about um in regards to the question on
the survey around guns um and so that
data is or can be directly related to
Legal means reduction in injury
prevention and suicide prevention and
could in the way that we use the data in
schools and in the community inform the
need for some messaging around gun
safety safe storage other you know
preventative measures from an injury
prevention suici prevention um type lens
so I just wanted to share that and hope
that that is some of what you were
looking for in asking that
question um so as one of the state's 13
Regional public health networks I work
with schools and other partners from
across our communities to work to
improve the health wellness and quality
of life for everybody in our communities
and that um usually first and foremost
includes our youth um and so we use the
ybs data as the public health network
our schools use the ybs data our
community organizations Healthcare
entities Etc use this data to identify
as a as a vital tool in our strategic
planning process so we use this data to
inform you know what are our kids seeing
what are the students and youth in our
communities facing what challenges are
there what are the underlying
issues having the opt out process allows
us this reliable representative data and
that represent reprentative data is
collected through an evidence-based
youth risk behavior survey it's a
nationally recognized evidence-based
tool that gives us the most accurate and
informative data that we use to do our
work we
develop policies programs practices um
it has been used by schools in our
region um that shared with me they were
able to use the data around mental
health and substance use to justify
adding um a licensed alcohol and drug
counselor onto their staff um and that
has positively improved the health and
well-being mental health substance use
data that was there was
followed um in speaking to the optin
versus opt out process um I
also oppose the amendment to um create
an opt-in process because not only would
it create an un unnecessary
administrative burden that would not
take 10 minutes of time between our
schools and those who support the
schools and administering the ybs um the
opt out process is widely supported on
the handout that I shared um
participation in active active consent
can very likely create a biased sample
meaning that those who are at highest
risk for some of risky some of the risk
behaviors or some of the issues
highlighted in the ybs are likely to be
those who do not receive active opin
consent to participate in this survey
and so our data would be skewed and
unreliable and it would hinder our
ability to accurately and or to
accurately support the students in our
our
schools and I'm happy to take questions
I'm not going to read my my testimony
for being thank you thank you very much
um any questions
c n thank you very much thank you and
thank you for the written testimony I'm
sure the clerk appreciates that
Elizabeth
Bru close on the last name at all oh you
did it you you pronounced it perfectly
thank you uh my name is Elizabeth brochu
I am the Project Director for uh getting
to Y New Hampshire it is a new program
um that was executed by the governor and
Council um in the past in December of
last year um we did have a kickoff in
January um we have currently been
working with uh New Hampshire high
schools and working with youth in
particular um looking at their yrbs data
um and teaching them how to actually
look at this data and find Solutions s
to bring to their peers so they are
actively involved in the ybs so what we
are doing with the the getting to Y
which is an up forlearning program which
is across the Vermont whole state of
Vermont um we are spreading this
program uh Statewide in New Hampshire we
currently have 23 high schools that are
active and um participating and getting
to why New Hampshire so we have students
look looking at this ybs data and they
are finding solutions for their peers I
do have my card if you would like to uh
learn more I will be following up today
with more information I will email you
all the information on getting to Y as
well as our March newsletter um with uh
quotes from students around New
Hampshire and parents are even uh loving
this opportunity to empower their
children to look at this data and become
change agents in the in New Hampshire I
would like to um finish my testimony
with a quote from Lucas Legacy he is a
Plymouth Regional High School student he
was trained this past last month um at
in Plymouth uh at the Common Man Inn um
along with three other schools and he he
quotes what's different in my experience
with getting to why compared to other
clubs that I am in is that getting to Y
is purposeful many people do different
things for various reasons but the only
one I have found to be both engaging and
long lasting is something that has
purpose getting to why emulates that
perfectly so I would like to open it up
for any questions I actually just came
from a training in Milford where we had
three schools Keen High School s heagan
high school as well as um Milford high
school so it's been pretty pretty
exciting thank you very much you're
welcome any questions yes repres try
thank you thank you for taking my
question yes explain getting to why yes
getting to why is a program which brings
adults and youth together looking at
their ybs data the y stands for youth
they're doing this they're doing the
work they're looking at this data and it
youth do not get to see their YB ster
they take this this survey but they are
not able to actually view the results so
this program brings them into the
decision-making they're looking at the
data they're looking at what their peers
are talking about they're they're
telling us the why why is this happening
so that's what the why stands for the
Youth as well as why are all of these
these outcomes actually happening in the
ybs so it's it's a very exciting program
you're
welcome thank you very much you're
welcome Julie Kim oh you have a question
I'm sorry yes so your program was
approved by the governor in Council um
and I suppose given money to proceed
knowing it was based on the data that
you got from the youth risk survey okay
so they understood you were using the
data from the
what
huhb y RBS yes okay thank you very much
you're welcome thank you any others
thanks thank you very much my
Kim thank you for having me today uh
committee and chair I am Dr Julie Kim
I'm a pediatric oncologist here in New
Hampshire for over 20 years I've raised
my children in New Hampshire
but more importantly at for today I am
the President of the New Hampshire
chapter of the American Academy of
Pediatrics and I represent over 20 over
200 pediatricians in our state our
pediatricians here want you to oppose
House Bill 4 446 we need to keep this
survey as an opt out survey so we can
get the best data possible the yrbs is
as you heard is a national survey
conducted by the Centers for Disease
Control and prevention prevention is a
big word here we are trying to prevent
things from happening that could go bad
it is completely Anonymous there's
actually no interactive followup with
any specific individual but the
information could be used to help a
group of like a school for example for
pediatricians this information is
important because it helps um guide what
we're going to talk to our patients
about uh it could be about their mental
health we may see it might be a new drug
that's coming out an illicit drug that
we don't know about now but the the
teens are knowing about it we can't
actually identify the answers to a
specific
child so that that data is uh is
anonymous and the survey is voluntary so
parents can actually review the actual
survey questions online and they know
about 10 days in advance about that this
survey is going to be given so they do
have the opportunity to opt out if they
don't want their child to participate as
you've heard it's a scientifically
validated survey and we know from
science that asking a question about
risky Behavior does not cause someone to
engage in that behavior instead it could
be a communication tool hopefully we
have uh we all want to have open
communication with our children this
survey could be a discussion point
between the child and family about what
was in the survey this survey learns us
helps us to learn more about health
rated behaviors and it that contribute
to leading causes of death we don't
learn just about risky Behavior but we
as pediatricians and as the community
learn about obesity phys physical
activity diet and Asthma even it gives
us a chance to implement programs and to
improve health health and
safety as I mentioned we all want to
have open communication with our teens
but some teens who are struggling may
not have a listening ear for them but
this survey could be somewhat of a proxy
for them we need to know what is
happening this information is important
to in getting the most accurate
information so we can help these
children so I ask you to oppose HB 446
which proposes this change to an opt-in
Pro process this will create more
administrative work will create delays
it will result in much fewer teens
completing the survey and the teens that
need the most help may actually be at
the most risk of not being able to
participate this current process with
the opt out is working and doesn't not
need to be changed the survey does not
lead to risky behaviors and it's not
about parenting or parental rights
parents as I said have the option to opt
their child out this survey is about
getting the most accurate information
and gives us a chance to intervene when
thank you very much represent Morris
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question you mentioned a little while
ago about identifying a new drug but how
would you be able to do that if there's
no question on the survey to kind of add
or tweet the survey may be about
substance use um but it allows us to
know that there's something going on we
can look at Trends and see if there's
something different and we may have to
investigate further about what that
difference
is thank you very much for being here
providing your testimony
Becky
Wilson uh good afternoon chairman
cordelli and members of the committee uh
I'm working off my phone I've been here
so long today my computer is dead um
thank you for hearing my testimony today
uh I appreciate the opportunity for the
record I'm Becky Wilson representing the
New Hampshire school boards Association
I was not going to testify on this bill
I know some of you have heard uh NH
hba's testimony on versions of this bill
over the past several sessions however I
just wanted to clarify um and offer a
few thoughts based on some of the
previous testimony and some of the
questions and concerns that have come
from members of the committee um to
reiterate uh each year Our member School
boards vote on resolutions um and
statements of belief uh to help Drive
their advocacy positions for the Year
this past fall um our nsba members again
affirmed two specific um um resolutions
regarding consent um nsba supports
language in legislation that provides
parents the right to opt out of content
and programs they feel are not
appropriate for their children however
nhba opposes language requiring parents
to opt into content and programs for
their children of which we would
consider the yrbs specifically to that
um the opt-in language creates an undue
burden on the school district to account
for every student who would participate
versus the few who choose not to
participate uh that resolution has been
in place since 2017 so it is not new um
there was a new resolution as well this
year that came from Member school boards
asking the nsba to support legislation
that would require the state to fund the
cost of the yrbs for the middle schools
in the state that want to uh provide
that to the middle schools so there's a
lot of value that is given to the yrbs
by school districts and to local
communities um the state does fund the
high school version of that um the
middle school version if a District
chooses to take to offer that they have
to take the cost for that so there was a
genuine effort to try to secure more
funding for that given the value that it
provides school districts I just want to
reiterate again that the local school
board does have to take a vote to accept
um the yrbs and to offer it to their
school district that is done at a
publicly noticed meeting that parents
and community members would be obviously
uh well aware is happening it would be
on the agenda um that would be a great
place for people to ask questions to the
local school board if they had questions
about what people are using it for um
many districts do take the results once
they're available and offer a
presentation at a local Schoolboard
meeting that is publicly noticed as well
to look at the re and review the results
that I think you've heard previous
speakers talk about that are available
at the district level um that's to
assist schools and communities um to try
to ensure that they're tailoring their
programs and their resources to actual
needs of students as opposed to what um
adults in the room are guessing are the
students needs sometimes we are not
correct I don't know if any of you have
ever had middle or high school students
sometimes what we think um they're
concerned about or are happening are not
necessarily what is actually happening
um and just to also you know clarify
that while this this is an informational
survey and is anonymous again um
sometimes I think I've heard it many
times by sponsors of this bill that it's
taken as a joke um middle and high
school students often make jokes about
things because it is a lot easier to
make a joke than it is to talk about
difficult things with your peers or your
family um this is an opportunity to try
to get real information from students
that can be used for those purposes um
lastly I would just say the ability to
communicate the survey results year
after year at locally uh local
Schoolboard meetings that are public is
a
transparency Pro it gives the community
an opportunity to look at resources that
have been secured as a result of some of
the yrbs data and make sure the
resources are actually working and that
taxpayer dollars are going to programs
for communities and families that
actually have a positive impact um
lastly I will just say quickly
representative that some of this
legislature specifically has put into
place a number of other resources for
students that do not provide uh direct
contact to parents that deal with
students who are struggling putting the
ID C uh number for on the back of ID
cards for the suicide prevention hotline
for the Eating Disorders hotline for one
trusted adult some of those things don't
necessarily have a other end where
people are calling parents immediately
after they get off the phone with
students the yrbs is no different I know
that this committee cares a great deal
about students well-being and I think
this is just one other manner of getting
to that I'm happy to take any questions
much will uh end the hearing on uh House
Bill 446 and uh start up the hearing on
431 Amendment
um yeah we have some paperwork to fill
out for the clerk and in the meantime we
pass around
um the
ready we'll open the hearing on HB 431
or the non non- gerain amendment to HB
431 establishing a commission to study
the costs of special education and I
recognize the sponsor representative
cordelli thank you very much um for the
record Glenn cordelli representing tuon
bro wolf bro and O and beautiful Lakes
Region and uh this
amendment
um Let me let me just say that we just
heard about the importance of data and
making decisions that's what this
amendment is about um we have heard from
our constituents we've heard here in the
uh legislative office building about
special education costs and what is
driving uh increased costs for special
education
increased numbers of students who have
been identified as special education um
that is some of what the proposed
Commission in this amendment is going to
try to get at uh on the first page
you'll see the establishment of the
commi commission and the membership uh
but most importantly I wanted to get it
down to Roman 3 and what the uh
commission is uh supposed to be looking
at um uh it starts with uh referral
rates I just mentioned um we've had um a
fairly constant number of students being
identified as special education but at
the same time enrollment has decreased
uh considerably so the percentage of
students being identified has gone up
considerably um why is that why are uh
students being labeled as other health
impaired what are the parameters of that
um we have uh Federal Ida categories 13
categories and some national uh
percentages um for each of those
categories some which
correspond uh somewhat to uh information
from here in New Hampshire some that do
not and we need to look at
that uh has there been any increase in
referrals since the start of the covid
pandemic um there is antidotal
um uh then we also want to definitely
look at the cost data um and some of
that is on page two um you know there
are services that are provided that are
not medically necessary
what are those
costs um and uh how is that
increasing um is that part of IEP goals
uh and services uh for 504 plans we need
to look at that um we need to look at
the uh comp
comparison of what is required by
Ida what is required in state law but
then what is required in
rules there's a lot more in rules than
in either federal or state law we need
to look at that there was um an analysis
done in
2016 almost 10 years ago we need to look
at that and is uh are our rules out of
line with state and federal law and is
that part of the driving uh for
increased cost for special educ
education and increased identification
of
children
um local districts uh reporting of cost
to uh to the Department of Education
there is some data being reported from
the districts and you've all all heard
mention of the doe
25 um form that is used to provide data
from the um local districts uh we need
to look at that data and look at
possible expansion of the data that's
being reported from local districts to
the department on those
costs um we also know from the um last
audit that was done that local districts
can come up with their own plans for due
process hearings their own programs that
the state doesn't even know
about we need to look at that and
determine um if those programs are being
useful perhaps they should be Statewide
if they
are uh Medicaid to schools is a large
program um the last number I saw was um
something uh above $10
million um to school districts in
Billing for Medicaid
services um we need to look at that um
the
reimbursement uh who uses those funds
when reimbursements are made for
services where do those funds go do they
go back into special education do they
go back to the district do they go back
to the town we need to get a handle on
that um I've heard anotated that some
districts use outside billing
services for this some do it inhouse we
need to look at that I've heard of a
district that uses a billing service in
Texas actually um so is the billing
being done
efficiently and what are the categories
and reimbursement rates for these
Services
um we've always heard about the um use
of legal services in special education
for IEPs for due process hearings uh but
that those
legal costs are covered by Insurance
paid by the districts I'd like to get a
handle on that what are the insurance
costs that are uh being paid by
districts um in terms of the students um
what are the graduation rates by the
type of U uh
diploma um that they are getting um
let's have a breakdown of that um so I
think those are some of the the main
things that um we would like this
commission to look at but certainly um
the number of students being identified
and the costs um as we've talked about
uh we know that this catastrophic Aid
that's now called special education aid
for um The High um cost uh Services
provided to some students but the real
dollar
that is being paid by districts and by
the state are not for those students but
for all the other students this
something um the number 800 sticks in my
mind of of those students compared to
the other uh 30 plus thousand um that
are uh um in one of the other 13 uh
categories as defined by
Ida um and so those are some of the
costs we need to look at
also uh so that is the purpose of this
commission and I think um we need to get
the uh a handle on this and look at the
costs because um we've heard about the
complaints from local districts about
the cost of special education and we
need to um get a handle on it so we can
try and do something about it and help
um both parents and school districts and
the state in terms of the costs thank
you thank you are there any questions
representative Hall thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question so when you say we need to get
a handle on the cost are you also saying
we need to get a handle on how many kids
are identified I mean it sounds like
from your presentation that we have too
many kids being identified and when I
look at U that was my question but
number 20 uh line 29 whether there are
interventions I mean that struck me I
thought in my experience in the
classroom we could not re refer unless
we tried a number of interventions
before we could even go through the
referral process so I guess that right
but my question is um on the number of
kids are identif right yes I want to
take a look at the number I think we
need to take a look at the number of
kids because the percentages have gone
up thank you representative Murray uh
thank you madam chair um with regard to
um I think you mentioned Insurance costs
paid by districts um I think
we're I want to make sure we're not
running up against any thing that could
be construed is related to Hippa or any
of those types of things so how are you
ensuring that when this information is
being looked at it is being looked at in
a way that comports with all of those
guidelines um uh uh I'm not sure about H
but I'd have to go back I I'm not sure
if uh uh well I'll leave it at that I I
want to look at that some more um but uh
yeah I don't see Insurance costs um not
necessarily um at the individual level
but at the school
level and follow up if I follow up thank
you um Madam chair and um with regard to
um I think you had said just um about
rules and rul making Authority it is
generally the legislature that empowers
rulemaking Authority or suggest that it
goes to that step
so if we are silent in the legislative
process on things that ultimately go to
um I I I guess what I'm asking
is where what would the fact finding be
I guess because the silence in the
legislature then says okay rule making
kicks it I I don't think that that is
the case rules are supposed to have a
legislative uh Source related to them so
I I um I think it's a problem um when
rules are prolongated um without um a
legislative
Source
followup what I'm talking about is when
the statute is written though it says
rule making Authority shall be granted
right right and so I guess that's what
I'm saying I'm looking I'm looking at um
things and rules that um
have no pain in legislative there is no
uh statement as under a section um that
says and rules shall be um approved by
the state board for X
um I I so I think that
um I think there is clearly uh I I
remember um I used to be on heak home
education advisory Council and we did um
an exhaustive view because there was
many things in
rules that were not covered in State
Statute related to requirements uh for
homeschool parents so we had to go back
and filter and revise the rules to come
in line with f in with state law and I
think we need to look at uh special ed
rules and see what rules are in place
that um go beyond what's in state or
federal law and if there if it's a good
practice that's in rules it should be
also in uh in state
law representative
bbon thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question um my question is
uh again go back to the audit that's
currently being done by the in the
department of special education I would
think that a lot of these um items that
you have in here are are going to be
addressed in the AUD it so my question
is why um are you putting forward this
piece of legislation now instead of
doing it through a regular
process um I think it is that imperative
um I'm not sure what the LBA will um
find related to this in their audit um
but they are dealing specifically with
the Department they're not touching
followup um yeah the followup would be I
it just seems to me to be premature to
again to do anything without
understanding what is what issues might
be within the department with you know
you start there first and if you then
there there then you might look at
whatever the local issues would be so I
I would just wonder again um the the
need to put this spill forward right now
and I question
that I think I answered that question
representa Murray yes thank you in all
sincerity I I I have another question
with regard to the timeline here of how
long this commission is established for
um this is a lot of data digging a lot
of conversation that might include the
federal government getting data back
from them regarding idea and certain
other things your first initial report
is requested back November 1 of 2025 and
I'm just curious to know whether or not
there would be any
substantive data that could be that's
seven months I I would hope so um and I
put that date in so that if there was um
information that came to the commission
um that could be put into legislation
for
20126 um I think would be important to
have an interim report at that point for
any um legislation for next year rather
year any other questions
seeing none thank you oh I'm sorry
representative um could you if this was
imperative and you know what not why was
it not introduced as legislation by its
own as opposed to being tagged onto as a
non-gain
Amendment
um I I had a lot of uh ideas for
legislation floating in my head um back
in September and November
uh some made it out of my head onto
paper some
kind second one follow okay um you did
also mention uh the local level and as I
look at lines 19 to 24 it doesn't look
like local is really there is
it of the people serving on
okay but those okay hold
committee um excuse me represent B Bon
thank you um thank you for taking my
question um just follow up on on
representative Hall's question it just
uh if um this is to address issues in
local districts um it appears if I'm
reading this correctly on the members
and the committee there's nobody
actually representing the local uh
school districts that could provide a
perspective uh the commission can invite
anyone they choose into uh into testify
and uh discuss uh questions with
them followup follow
um but the difference would be um if you
provide people in to give input but
you're not giving them a seat at the
table to when you're talking about
recommendations being given so I would
again I'm wondering would you consider
having representatives from local
districts special education
administrators people that are involved
in the field be part of this uh
commission uh I I think um here at the
committee we've get lots of of
testifying one more question
representative Murry thanks uh
chairwoman Noble um my other question
was whether or not this was looking
at like from preschool early
identification I mean what is the scope
how are we looking through age 21 or is
it preschool to 21 what are we what are
we doing here I I wasn't considering
preschool um but I I know the child find
statutes and everything like that um but
I'm looking really at uh K12 covering
through for special edits 21 inclusive
point very
minor um I
I when you're talking about
identification for special ed services
though is it not true that it includes
preschool aged children right via child
find and yes um but you know certainly
child find um could be you know
something else to be looked at you know
what's what is going on with child find
in in
districts thank you okay thank you you
are free thank you can I leave no not
thank you madam chair and committee for
allowing me to speak today um a couple
of points and questions that were asked
I would just add to um to get that sense
of costs and where those costs are
coming from right um in terms of the
services we provided I would like to
throw out a couple other stakeholder
groups that you might want to consider
in the composition under your um sorry
I'm losing my voice today under your um
uh your committee um section which is I
believe um lines 14 through 24 on page
one um three stakeholder groups that
came to mind as I read through this
amendment that I think would be valuable
on this commission is um what we call
Related services this would be our PT
our OT our speech school psychologist
even SCH
counselor and the reason why I'm
suggesting that you consider that as
part of your composition of your
commission is because these are going to
be folks that when you go to page two of
the amendment and it says um it's line
one through three up there with the cost
to provide services which are not
medically necessary these are the folks
that are going to be able to give you
some real insights like hey how much
does it actually cost for a 30 minute OT
session and you guys don't want to hear
that cost right now I can tell you so I
would say something in that realm a
couple representatives from your related
Services the second stakeholder group
that I thought was um would would be a
nice crossover and also align um two
lines 29 and 30 on page one that was
already brought up about um the
interventions that are deployed before
we do a referral process so I would say
I'm going to use an Acron but then I'll
say it I would say you want some sort of
mtss expert multi-tiered systems of
support and we have some really great
Folks at the Department of Education in
that role so maybe you pull an mtss
person from the Department of Education
they would really be a nice crossover
because this is where I saw in the
commission proposal of a crossover
between special education and general
education um because we do we have very
delineated three tier model in our mtss
process um and very right we usually
before we even go to referral say okay
in tier one we did this in tier two in
tier three you know and this is why it's
not working so I think something from
that realm would be good
representation and you know me I'm going
to be the voice of Educators I would
Advocate that on line 17 it's great we
have one special education educator
appointed but I I can tell you that
special ed services look different at
your three major grade bands elementary
middle and high school so you might want
to think about maybe that could be one
special education administrator CU that
organization would like put forth a
director of student services or
something and then maybe a
representative teaching sample of the
special ed services that might happen at
the grade levels um the only cause for
concern I have in the amendment is um
online 27 on Page One Part B it says why
students may be labeled other health
impaired um that is actually defined in
the Federal Regulations I think it's
3.8 don't quote me on this might be C9
but um it will break down like what we H
what the child has to present um in
terms of um physical and emotional
deficits to qualify for that Ohi so it
may be worthy on that line I I agree it
would be nice to see a breakdown of
which categories in that federal statute
are causing more of those Ohi
classifications um so maybe something in
the language pointing back to that
federal statute to say we're going to
get the categories from there um uh I
have to agree with representative
cordelli um I loved his statement when
he said we need to get some of these
rules in line with our laws and that is
very true that's what we often deal with
in the field is we look at the law we
look at the rule and we go wait a minute
there's an in congruence here how do we
figure this out right and we're kind of
caught in the middle um so I think
having the commission focused on that um
would be really good um the only thing I
would offer I mean as a as a a co-author
with represent Damon on
431 is I wonder about why the complete
replacement of 431 for this I think both
commissions are valuable and I think
studying the cost of special education
is important but I also think our
commission on 306 is important so I I
wonder about the language
in the opening part of amend the title
or amend the bill by replacing all I
mean I'd certainly like to see this as
an amendment but not in place of the
commission for
306 thank you are there any
questions representative
Lichfield thank you madam chairman and
thank you for taking my question it it's
it's twofold if that's okay please um so
the first part is when you mentioned um
consider adding under the committee
there were three different um
stakeholders you mentioned and I I
missed it so I I don't know how to word
it but you have elementary middle and
high school and I have one special
education administrator would it be one
representative that covers all three are
you saying one from the elementary one
from the middle one from the high school
I would take one from the elementary one
from the middle from the high school and
then get an admin a special ed admin
because those key players are going to
give you much different perspectives
that elementary middle or high school
special ed teachers going to be able to
actually describe to you the services
that are happening where that special ed
director is then going to be able to say
and this comes at a cost of X Y and Z
because the teachers don't always get
into the weeds with the cost it's the
administrators yeah follow yes please
thank you um I'm going to just make it
into a really long run on sentence so I
can fit okay both in um so my thoughts
my only concern is when we add these
other stakeholders which I'm not saying
it's not valid I think the commission
goes up to at least 20 people I just
don't know if that's like hurting cats
that being said early
intervention um it starts at age three
right I'm just I'm drawing a blank at
that point that does fall under the
umbrella of billing for the taxpayers in
the public school level doesn't it and
okay so if it does would we want someone
at the preschool level or is Elementary
is Elementary
Encompass the I'm just asking is
Elementary Compass Age 3 to 3 to six so
we actually have a couple different
certifications around that so we
actually have what's called an N through
three that's your preschool through
three special educator then we actually
have a general special education
endorsement and we also can do like an
elementary aada 6 type endorsement so
there's different endorsements I think
whoever you go with you might want to go
with somebody that's got the if you're
going Elementary that's the true
experience of also having preschool with
them I don't know if you need to
separate out of preschool and an
elementary I think you can find people
just like if you were concerned about
the size of the commission maybe instead
of doing elementary middle and high
school you do like a and it widens the
range a bit you do maybe like a um prek
to 8 because we do have a lot of schools
still in New Hampshire that are that
prek to8 setting um and then you do a
high school but I mean that prek to
person i' probably want to say they've
done a little bit of all of it the early
the middle level that kind of thing yeah
thank you any other question
representative
wock good afternoon thank for being here
um you were consumed with a 306 uh
project um not having that background
what do you anticipate something of this
magnitude might take in time because I
know that pres cordelli has I think
someone brought up a very aggressive
timeline how realistic is that timeline
what would you suggest I I think like I
said I think this commission is valuable
we need to do this study in New
Hampshire um I I think it's very
aggressive um and I would be concerned
about getting the data um the first
report being in November um I I I mean
when you think about forming a
commission you get everybody in it right
the purpose you set the parameters the
workload and then I mean there's a lot
of things that are going to need to be
pulled from data and I'm not sure always
that data is going to be that easy to
pull in some instances um so timeline
for me would be I would think at least
minimum a first report would be a year
from the establishment of the commission
um and you know I I think also I think
of the genocide and Holocaust commission
right they are still running um and
their purpose has shifted over time and
I think this is a commission that could
do the same so maybe your first report
would come a year later right and then
perhaps a in year two your goal is to
actually recommend and make some
substantial changes you know to how it's
going on and then I would think the
commission would want to shift almost to
like a monitoring responsibility like
okay we're making these changes are they
making a difference um I think there's
some opportunity here um when I spoke
earlier in the week about the task force
on adequate education right the this is
some parallel work here that could come
together thank you thank you much Madam
chair representative
Bon thank you madam chair thank you to
taking my question on page two um on the
first line I'm I'm not exactly sure and
I'm hoping you can give me uh some
guidance on this it says the cost to
provide services which are not medically
necessary as defined by Medicaid um can
you tell me what what those Services
might be so for example um one service
might be and this is why I also said you
might want to get that mtss expert onto
it so something that's not medically
that we wouldn't Bill necessary to
Medicaid let's say a student on an IEP
has a reading goal and we know the best
person in the building to meet that
would actually be our certified reading
specialist okay so how do you figure out
what exactly is the cost of that right
towards those Services because that
reading specialist is not just a
one-on-one to that child but their time
time right salary B you you could cost
out on a pro-rated ratio what does that
cost um and and that's I'm I'm I mean I
would defer to representing cordelli but
when I read that statement that's what
came to my mind is like what can I not
Bill to
Medicaid any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
good afternoon I'm Karen Rosenberg I'm
the policy director at the disability
rights Center New Hampshire's protection
and advocacy system for people with
disabilities I have um been an attorney
before being policy director which I've
been for about three and a half years or
so um I was a senior staff attorney at
the disability rights Center um
beginning in around the fall of 2005 and
handled a lot of Special Education cases
for parents and children with
educational
disabilities um so I understand we there
are concerns about education funding
across the board right and this has been
a struggle for our state it's a struggle
for your parallel committee to try to
figure out what our costs are and how to
fund education appropriately it's in the
courts it's everywhere um not sure that
this commission is going to necessarily
get you there and I have some concerns
about what it is exactly that this
commission would be examining and
whether the appropriate voices are all
represented on this commission as
proposed so um first of all I mean you
all know that um education for children
with disabilities is you know arises out
of a very robust Federal statutory
scheme there are federal regulations
there are state laws and state
regulations which I need to say are
actually valid they're all over 186c
there are um indications where the
Department of Education needs to promate
rules it's it's replete through the
statute like around what child with
disability means or what the process is
to be identified for Education what's in
an IEP there it just all of this is in
our statute and the Department of
Education is expected to promulgate
rules about that just am I bonded about
that one so I think that you know it
would be interesting to learn more about
um and and try to figure out whether we
are actually maximizing funding that's
available to defay the cost of of
special education and related Services I
know that right now the Department of
Health and Human Services is undergoing
a transformation on how we do billing
for Medicaid to schools and they and so
that is changing a bit with a goal I
believe to make it a little bit easier
and more and have it be a more robust
funding source but that is in process as
I understand it a more robust funding
source for schools um in addition I
think that
um the um we need to look if we're going
to look at funding we also need to look
at outcomes are we getting the outcomes
that we want and we also need to make
sure that parents' voices and the voices
of people who are impacted are
adequately represented and I would
suggest that if I I'm not sure this
commission is necessary but if it were
necessary I would suggest adding an
organization like ours that here advises
around 200 parents a year who's and
represent some of them in these kinds of
in disputes around special education
that has been involved in the rul making
or parent information center that
probably talks to even more parents than
we do on special education issues um
because we have sort of knowledge about
what's going on Statewide in schools and
where there might be gaps there are
certain aspects of of what this
commission would study that are actually
available to it already or that can't be
necessarily changed so for example there
is already a definition for what Ohi or
other health impairment is that's not
something this commission can change um
this notion that imple that
interventions could be implemented
before referral there are times when
that would be highly illegal if you
already have evaluations that would
identify some a student as having an
educational disability and requiring
special education it would be unlawful
to to hold up that child's
identification
um I think that the person who testified
that before me talked about how services
medical necessity and Medicaid not every
student with an IEP is Medicaid eligible
not every Educational Service that they
receive is a medical service um but if
it's required in their IEP it's required
to be Prov provided
so just knowing that and knowing that
we're in the process of revising how
school districts get reimbursed I'm not
sure this is a good time to study that
particularly um as far as the um
comparison of what's required under
federal law versus our state law our
current state law already requires the
Department of Education to file an
annual report on any rules that are that
exceed the federal minimum rules so that
information exists and you all need to
know that the rule making process as you
know is a very public process there is
input there is a lot of work on this and
there are really good reasons why some
of our rules are different from what is
in the base of in the federal
regulations and mostly it's to encourage
and make it feasible for parents to
participate in their children's
education we feel it's really important
for parents to have a voice in these
meetings and to get the information that
they need ahead of time so like I said
the information is there the rules are
there for a reason um and there you know
there is a rul making process that takes
input um I'm concerned about some of the
data being subject to furpa so you'd
have to be really careful to make sure
furpa is the federal law that protects
students educational records
confidentiality protections so if you're
looking at things like um cost F
District placement and whether other
options were available I'm not sure what
that means but that seems like it could
be a bit r risky in terms of identifying
students and revealing confidential
information
um I yeah I'm trying I'm looking at some
of these other categories um I think
that if school districts are paying
attorneys and using and having insurance
I think that information would probably
be available under our right to know law
um if there those kinds of contracts um
would probably be so I think there's
other ways to get information like this
um so I I don't know I I I I think that
there's a lot to consider here um it's
being considered pretty close to
crossover day and when all these
decisions have to be made so um I I
don't know I think I like I said it
raises an eyebrow for me and my office
and I'm happy to take
questions thank you representative
Murray uh thank you madam chair I did
have a question this is on page two um
line um
oh it's regarding the stratification of
types of diplomas I've just lost it for
a yeah we don't we do report on I mean a
diploma is a regular education diploma
so that's the only legitimate diploma
and what idea looks at and what our
state is required to report on already
is the percentage of students with IEPs
who obtain a regular education diploma
and that's when their eligibility for um
um special education would terminate
once they achieve that regular Ed
diploma so there's not really another
diploma similarly um with like due
process like I I guess that there was
something that passed but the federal
law actually requires certain due
process for um students and when there
are educational disputes Al it requires
certain alternative dispute resolution
as well as certain um due process
procedur so I'm not sure about the value
of looking at local or um dispute
resolution or if that's even happening
in the state I'm a follow up follow up
and I guess you mentioned fura I also
potentially mentioned um Hippa concerns
um maybe I I I guess I'm just curious
about uh with respect to line 17 and
identifying the age of a graduate all of
these other types of things we could
inadvertently be waiting into ter
territory that
is well yeah sorry I guess it depends on
how narrowly you define age like the
Department of Education already report
has a standard for um and I let me see
if I pulled I tried to pull up their
annual report on graduation because I
have to reply report it to the federal
government let me think it's in the
up I I think it's the second indicator
let's
see of course I want find aw here we go
so indicator one so they look at
graduation rates already and I don't
know that they do it by age it's a
number of Youth
graduation per exiting special education
you know they don't look at the number
the age of a kid I think they um have to
be ages 14 to 21 that's a pretty
broad scope um I don't know how much
this commission would drill down but it
it well might be problematic if it you
can't identify kid in a smaller School
District it would be very
challenging thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you thanks
time
Beth hi my name is Beth Paige I'm from
Anover I'm a special education
administrator I have not been doing this
for too long only a few years
um and I have never spoken in front of a
legislative body in in my life so please
bear with me um but just from my
perspective uh there's been a lot of
good points that were made by the ladies
that sat here in front of me um there
was mention of a state audit which I
think is going to be really helpful in
answering some of these questions some
of these professionals have the the data
that you're looking for already and
they've spoken to that um I know that
special education professionals and
administrators could speak directly to
the costs and how um it just keeps
inflating every year year to year um it
feels like a lot of the things that are
listed in this amendment um are not in
any way related to the original
intention of HB
431 um this is speaking to creating a
commission uh seeking input and I think
representative cordelli referred to
allowing people to come and voice their
opinion in a legislative session of this
nature I might be misinterpreting his
language but it felt like if if if it's
advocated to have more directors at the
table who look at the costs dayto day we
need to be invited in or find the time
in our busy days to come down here and
and do such a thing as opposed to be
invited equally to the table at the
commission which was the point of the
representative I can't read your name on
your plaque I apologize um I think that
is also thank you the case for um the
original intent of HB 431 the point was
to create a commission to have an equal
playing field of of individuals who
could continue to uh refine revise and
develop our our base um education model
um as is appropriate as the years go on
um there were a lot of points that were
made to specific lines I do find it very
interesting that only one special
education educator appointed by our um
Association the the NAA Association
would be a part of this Commission
because those are the people again who
are you know monthly I'm required to
sign invoices on the contracts that I'm
required to sign for all of the services
that are in my district so um I don't
think that anyone other than those those
folks are very aware of what those costs
look like and why it is that they're
being uh contracted to provide there's
some costs that were spoken to earlier
um that were regarding line one on page
two um services that are not medically
necessary that involves a gamut of
academic social supports emotional
supports which um are not necessarily
tied to uh a medical need and to other
points that were made earlier not every
child qualifies for Medicaid
reimbursement so despite um whether not
we can get it refunded to us in a a
small portion because we do not get the
services funded wholly um you know we
are required to provide it to to provide
that um Vape that's required of us so
there's a lot of the points here I'm not
sure if it would be useful for me to go
through all all all these areas but
really I guess my bottom line is that
there is definitely a need to look at
special education costs I would
definitely agree to that there's also
definitely a need to establish the
commission that was the original intent
of HB 431 I think both are valid the
content of the amendment here there are
a lot of questions here that could be
answered by going to your local school
board and asking these questions of them
going to your local special education
administrator and your towns and asking
those questions starting those
conversations um because you know we we
do have policies in place on how it is
we determine if a child is other health
impaired we agree with you that the
increase in referrals since Co is an
issue you know um I think there's a lot
of points here that are valid but a lot
of points that could be answered outside
of a
commission thank you are there any
been a long day for all of you I know uh
for the record uh chairwoman Noble and
members of the committee thank you for
taking my testimony uh for the record
Becky Wilson from the New Hampshire
school boards Association and to give
some context I previously served as a
special education administrator for over
20 years here in the state um I will not
um keep everyone with a long lengthy
testimony I do just want to point out a
couple of things um I think it's very
important to say and it is critical to
remember that the basis of special
education is about access to General and
regular education the original portion
of this bill um was meant to I think
address general education and you cannot
untangle special education from regular
education so the fact that this
amendment is a replace all I'm not sure
that serves anyone very well because
you're trying to separate again uh a
students uh special special education
needs that are impacting their access to
general education that is why they are
identified as a student who requires
special education you cannot completely
separate that from general education and
look at two things in a silo um that
will not that that is not the intention
of special education nor is it ever um
and I think a lot of the aspects that
are covered in this amendment are trying
to do just that you're trying to really
separate out medical needs that are
being addressed in the school
environment m versus educational needs
it seems like that is part of the
intention of this I could be wrong um
but just in trying to find a thread with
all of the aspects that this commission
would cover it's difficult to try to
figure out what the thread is um there
there are some random things that seem
to be put into here in terms of I'm not
quite sure how they all go together if
the thread is not about medical needs of
students being addressed in the school
setting which I know is a concern of
some people on the committee and that's
a valid concern if that's what you want
to focus on but um this particular
commission the the areas that they're
trying to address I think is a little
bit um confusing in that regard um so a
couple of things that have not been said
referral rates by idea category for
special education programs um students
are not categorized when they are
referred they are referred to special
education so that you can determine as a
team what if any special education needs
they have and if so what eligibility
criteria they may meet and which
category of disability they may fall
under there are no referral rates by
category um so that's not a term that I
think people in the field would use uh
if you're trying to look at the outcomes
of evaluations or determinations of
Eligibility that might be a little bit
different um but I'm pretty sure that
over the last several sessions there
have been lots of bills looking at
categories of idea um designation uh
because we've been talking about
education funding as related to the
different categories for I don't know
probably six to eight years I would
imagine um so that information is
available um but you are not as a team
intentionally not trying to refer a
student based on some specific category
um why students may be labeled other
health impaired again it's been said
multiple times every single category and
special education in the state has a
determination eligibility form that lays
out the criteria that the student has to
meet in order to be identified under
that category there's 13 different
categories 13 different deliberations I
can share those with Jen and I'm sure
she can share them with you I thought I
already had shared them but I think that
was with the other education committee
I'm getting a little confused with all
the Committees um the increase in
referrals since covid closures I mean we
have talked a lot about this as well and
I just want to remind the committee that
while the school buildings were closed
New Hampshire was actually at the
Forefront of providing remote
instruction School itself was open
during covid there were I and again I
would have to go in the way back machine
to really pull all this information but
I there were very few schools that
provided nothing um whereas in other
states there were quite a few um states
that were not prepared for that
situation in terms of remote instruction
but New Hampshire actually had been
doing a lot of training at the
department of Ed on remote instruction
prior to co so while the school
buildings were closed and that certainly
has had a lot of impact on students and
staff and families um School itself was
not closed so you might want to get a
little clarification if that's an area
that you want to um study if this
amendment were to go forward
um but somebody already spoke about
interventions that can be implemented
prior to referrals um that is something
that is considered um when students are
referred for special education whether
or not interventions have been tried and
if so what was the students response um
a lot of that has come out of this
legislature in terms of mtss RTI trying
those different things to make sure you
are identifying students based on their
actual needs and not on a uh hole in the
system for example or lack of
appropriate instruction and that's
something that has to be considered for
every single deliberation whether or not
the student has had access to
appropriate instruction so um medically
necessary I think we've beat that dead
horse enough today um not all services
are medically necessary and and Medicaid
to schools is a completely different
program that has nothing to do with
Educational Services it has to do with
medically necessary Services provided in
a school setting um the rules and exess
chart already exists um I don't know in
terms of uh letter G the district
resport reporting of costs to the
Department of Ed I don't know what the
department of Ed feels maybe are costs
that they are missing or they're not
currently getting them or is it the
collection that they're not getting them
um also the Department's not part of the
IEP team and the IEP team has to make
decisions based on children's needs and
not on cost that is at the Forefront of
those so the department wouldn't be
getting those costs and team shouldn't
be making decisions solely based on cost
either so um that's a little bit of a
difficult sweet spot to find I believe
somebody already talked about out of
District placement and if a student goes
to out of District placement it's
because the team has has considered
other options and has decided that they
can't meet the students needs in those
options so yes other options are
available and the team has already
decided they're not appropriate um
locally District dispute resolutions
that bill just passed this committee
last session um so the school's been in
session for six months I'm not sure how
much viable information you would have
in that time um I won't just keep going
through this and going through this um
however graduation rates as well um yes
that information is available
um there's 13 to 15 indicators that
every single district is rated on every
year in terms of special education it's
available online for every single
District graduation rate is one of them
um you can get graduation rate for
students who are identified with
disabilities you can get graduation rate
for your whole District you can get
number of students who graduated with
their cohort which means in the four
years versus students that graduated
with a regular high school diploma but
took longer than four years you can get
all of that information so um I'll just
reiterate that I don't think you can
separate special education needs from
general education needs and so if
anything if this amendment were to go
forward um I would you know advocate for
trying to keep both things you need to
look at the General Ed system and if you
have a strong General Ed system you will
have a better special education system
the reason a lot of times that you have
inflated special education is because of
a lack of strong regular Ed and if you
don't have strong regular Ed the
students are going to show needs that
perhaps are um maybe not as closely tied
to special education as they could be
I'm happy to take any questions although
I'm sure you don't want to ask
many thank you representative Murray
thank you representative Noble I did
just want to make sure that I was clear
in understanding that you do or do not
concur with the fact that there is not a
segregated type of diploma for children
correct it is a general diploma thank
you for the question represent ative
some districts um offer an alternative
diploma that is a district diploma
versus the state diploma there's still
requirements that the the diploma has to
meet however in terms of special
education the student is eligible to
remain in the school system or get
special education services until they
obtain a regular high school diploma or
they turn 22 that even if they were to
get their GED or their highet or some
alternative diploma they would still be
eligible to receive services and the
school district would need to provide
those until they get a regular Ed
diploma you're welcome representative
wuk thank you um Mr Wilson thank you for
being here are saying this along um
based on your knowledge of special Aid
which is you know huge um and looking at
the the the uh magnitude of this
commission's responsibilities in in
investigation how long do you think it
would take to approximately do an
adequate job I guess I'm concerned about
the timelines we' talked about before
what in your ballpark what would you
think in
now thank you for the question
representative Woodcock I I think
there's a two things that I would
consider one is the fact that somebody
else already mentioned Medicaid to
schools is undergoing an enormous
overhaul right now which is going to
change to cost-based reporting which is
going to allow districts to actually
recoup the actual cost of what they are
spending that is not set to go into
place until 2026 school year and there
is a lot of training that is supposed to
be happening at the district level
between this summer and next the 2026
summer um through DHHS that RFP went to
governor and Council months ago and I
think that has been secured um so if
nothing else because so many of these
questions are related to Medicaid and
Medicaid type questions I would suggest
waiting until that is up and going
because right now if you were to pull
this commission together and try to get
something out you are what's reimbursed
by Medicaid or what districts are paying
Etc is based on the Medicaid rates which
are set by insurance by Medicaid they
have nothing to do with what schools are
actually paying so they're being tracked
that way so you're not going to get
great answers um you know you've got
again I think multiple Pathways in this
commission that you're looking at you're
looking sort of at like programmatic
things that are being offered at the
school you're looking at Medicaid to
schools um so at least a year at least a
year if from from the fall two years I
mean I don't know by the end of the
session I it's a very it's a lot of
questions um and education funding I is
also asking and doing a lot of this work
already so I don't know if you're
creating sort of a competitive
commission with what the other housed
committee is also already
addressing thank you representative
Murray uh thank you madam chair um I I
just want to make sure I'm understanding
correctly too is it your statement that
potentially we could spend all this time
energy money and resources into to
getting all of this data and then our
the Medicaid overhaul sort of hasn't
even really launched yet so this could
potentially provide misleading
information that is not fully capturing
the new changes thank you for the
question represent Mari yes as in
regards to the questions in this
commission that are addressing Medicaid
to schools it's going to change who has
to report how they report what they're
asking to be reimbursed for um who's
doing the billing all of those pie and
some of that you know is addressed in
this commission so it certainly would
impact all of
that any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
thank you madam chair good afternoon
committee for the record state
representative hope Damon San District 8
I am going to take 30 seconds maybe
less are you asking me to
wait okay wasn't sure um I have
submitted to the clerk's office for the
bill to be withdrawn since the amendment
completely Alters the purpose of the
original bill and we will be voting um
not tomorrow but next Thursday at the
State House on the withdrawal of the
original version of HP 431 which I hope
to bring back next year and have a more
productive legislative process so we can
actually look at making a commission
happen on the 306 rules and
separately process the consideration of
a commission on special
education thank
you thank
you any
questions seeing
none okay you guys deserve a gold star
those of you who are still here must be
a couple people still